Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Sorry for being a little late.
I was downloading the Marvel Rivals preview build for
tomorrow.
Yes, whoa, the biggest plot twist of our lives.
The special stream on Twitch with drops is gonna be Marvel
Rivals.
Who could have expected this at all?
Oh, my God.
I know it's crazy.
But yes, tomorrow I will be streaming the season 6 preview
of Deadpool.
Yes, of Deadpool for season 6.
And we're going to be doing a special early access preview
with a bunch of other streamers tomorrow.
I will say Deadpool is fucking hard.
I like look tested.
I won't reveal everything because it's a you know gotta save
it for tomorrow but um for those who don't didn't see the
the trailers for it he is tank dps and support no gamut's
fucking easy he's such a fucking easy character it's just
literally cute to win um but yeah so he's tank dps and
support and he has like a skill tree for each role I thought
the was for like like to determine what role you're playing
but during the character select uh you can like you can pick
which Deadpool do you want to pick and also the the XP that
you get from uh the XP that you get transfers over to the
role so it's really funny because I was like oh shit like
it's like you you know if your team was like well we're
lacking support let me just swap to Deadpool as Oh, we need
another tank.
Don't worry.
I'll just swap to Deadpool as a tank and you keep your XP.
Yeah, you can just swap from DPS, but you have to be in the,
you have to be in the hero select for that.
You can't just swap randomly in the middle of the fight.
You have to actually be in the, in spawn to swap between,
like, between roles.
That's, I think the craziest part is that I was testing this
out and I was like thinking, Oh, um, oh, like, uh, if he is,
like, for each role, does that mean when you ban Deadpool,
you only ban the specific Deadpool for that role?
So then, because, like, I got thinking, I was like, if you
ban Deadpool, do you ban all the Deadpools, or do you ban
the Deadpool of each role?
It's of each role.
It's like, I got to, guys you if you use all three all three
of your bands you can ban Deadpool but you have to use all
three of your band yeah you have to use all three bands to
ban the entire character because if you ban if you ban tank
Deadpool then like you only ban tank Deadpool so you have to
ban tank Deadpool support Deadpool and DPS Deadpool to ban
the entire Deadpool I know I'll show you guys it tomorrow
it's looking so it's so fucking funny I was like oh my god
what that shit is crazy he's like you can never get rid of
him he truly is unbattable um but yes anyway more details
about Deadpool tomorrow but um oh also my team okay it's
pretty Because it's like, I thought it was really funny.
So this is the team I'm going to be going against, guys.
Okay, let me grab.
I snipped it because I thought it was really funny.
I won't say why.
I just thought it was really funny.
So the team I'm playing against is Bougar, XQC, Moxie, J3,
Guru, and KG.
But then on my team, it's Shroud, Gael, Saipé, Flats, and
KC.
So I was like, that's funny.
That's really funny.
Doesn't matter which team I'm in.
It doesn't matter which team I'm in.
There's always going to be something.
I would have liked to be on Moxie's team, though.
moxie's team is definitely the the vibes team and then my
team is like the super serious people like saipe is so
fucking serious too um yeah i would have loved to be on yeah
moxie's team because moxie's team sounds really fun i think
my team sounds really try yeah yeah i think it's my team is
the sweaty no cop like yes only cop like if you use voice
chat it's only gonna be comm's voice chat type deal yeah not
actually no moxie moxie j3 boker um even xqc they're all
pretty fucking fun play people to play like like on a team
because i've done i've done sponsored streams um and rivals
with xqc with boker with uh moxie and with j3 and they're
all like super super vibes people they're all just like
content type people if you guys ever see my other marvel
arrivals uh sponsored oh yeah no we like i it that it's like
it's like pretty fucking silly we'd be like what are you
saying excuse me like it would just be like we just be
picking on him and stuff and it's just fun in general yeah
um if you guys ever see my have a sponsor stream it was i've
been on a team with these people before like individually
and like or like together um and stuff um and then uh but i
i know i've been on a team with gail and um gail he's like a
super serious player and i know cype is also an incredibly
serious player too because he's he's like the number one
he's number one two three and four and five oh yeah By the
way, it's really funny.
Saipay was number one, two, three, four, and five in Marvel
Rivals.
And people got really mad that he took up too many of the
top 500, the top 10 leaderboards of Marvel Rivals that
NetEase fucking demoted four of his accounts or like five of
his accounts back to like Eternity or some shit because
they're like, they're like, no, too many accounts in top.
No, they didn't ban his all the accounts.
They deranked his alt accounts back to the bottom of
eternity so he couldn't be top 500 again And you know what
he did?
He got back he got back ranked two three four and five He's
like all right bet I'll do it all over again And then he
fucking got back two three four and five Within like a
couple of days.
I know it's like there was no point There's no point in like
deranking him like you can't stop him like but yes i'm a
little nervous about tomorrow only because like um all the
players on my team are super serious and like that makes me
very nervous when everyone is super serious so i hope people
would be chill i hope i hope it'll be i hope um um my team
will be chill in the end too and just you know fuck around
too fuck around but also not get rolled That's all I hope
for.
I hope we can fuck around.
But also not get hard diff.
That's my goal here.
Because I personally think Moxie's team is definitely the
stronger team.
Because they have more people that play rivals regularly.
Plus it's top 500.
I think Moxie's team.
team has more top 500 players than my team because like I
don't play rivals as much anymore um because of my busy
schedule so I really do appreciate rival devs for inviting
me um uh for inviting me to the sponsors as well um and uh
and like I am a little nervous because their team is so
stacked their team is like a lot more stacked than us bro so
I can't carry all of us guys He is, guys, Rupert win my team
during the, what was it, the seven hours of hell where we
only play three games and we beat Sipe's team and we
technically, like he was, his team is ranked one, two,
three, and four and five.
And then my team still beat his team.
He can't carry all of us.
Like, we still were able to beat him, guys.
even though he is like one of the best support players in
the world right now um he is a whole top but he's the whole
top five in the leaderboard one man does not make the whole
team anyway other than that um other than that what else did
i want to tell you oh yes by the way um i'm sorry i like how
god of war is always getting cucked by marvel rivals but um
friday god of war is gonna get cooked by Marvel rivals
because um because I got into a rivals tournament super last
minute um so if you guys didn't know uh super I have no idea
if it's gonna if it's gonna overlap if it's gonna overlap
with the my god of war stream but um super is hosting a
Marvel rivals tournament and I messaged the devs asking like
oh are the spots filled like like last night I think it was
it was like last night And then I asked, and they're like,
oh, no, they just started recruiting people.
I was like, oh, yeah, do you think they'd like to have me?
And they're like, yeah, yeah, of course.
And so now I'm in the Super's Marvel Rivals tournament that
starts at 12 p.m.
PST on January 16th, which is also God of War.
So it might not cuck, it might not cuck the God of War
stream because I don't know, I don't think it'll go for five
hours.
So guys, it might not go for five hours, guys.
be okay we we might be okay but i will be in the friday
tournament i don't know who my teammates are though um uh i
have no idea who my teammates are like i said like i haven't
been sending information yet um i just asked if they're
still looking for people and they're like yeah we are so
then like they got the devs uh and the tournament organizer
got me in um literally this morning happened so fast.
I didn't think they were still looking.
Apparently, they started looking for people yesterday, but
they announced it yesterday.
So I was just like, I just, you know, took my shot because I
was like, maybe they still need like one or two players, you
know, because I was thinking like, oh, if they announced it
yesterday.
So I don't know, it could be like super finalized already
you know so um so i was just like oh okay maybe maybe
they're still looking for one or two more to fill up the
slots so i shot my shot and asked the devs and then they're
like and then the organizer and devs were like oh yeah we
just started recruiting people like like today after
announcing it and i'm like oh okay fuck yeah sign me up
again i was just like oh yeah fuck yeah sign me up i fucking
would love to enjoy um it worked out it worked out though um
because like i got in um so other than that another thing
i'm sorry it's all marvel rivalous don't worry i have
another topic i want to talk about that is not rivalous um
but another thing is that i really to talk about it because
I thought it was really fucking funny um but another a new
update they announced it in the trailer but a new update
that they that are adding is you can 1v1 people in time
square now like you can challenge people in the rivals time
square um for for money for your fucking currency so you can
be like like yeah you can actually like bet be like I would
to bet like those like the blue currency thing that you use
for yeah so you can literally like challenge people for 1v1s
yeah it's like a fucking fight club for actual like not real
I mean it is real money because it's the blue currency but
you can actually like bet against it and then like some of
my friends my pro friends are like yeah that's free money
but like the pros are gonna be like oh top square for free
buddy they're like bro like why not it's literally free
money they're just gonna be the pros they're just gonna be
like terrorizing the 1v1 lobbies now because they're like
yeah you want to bet guys are i'm totally i'm totally not a
pro player guys come on don't you want to 1v1 me that's your
assistant thank you the super chat thank you thank you your
fight be streamed on the big screen on the lobby thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you no apparently it's
like you can like win actual like uh you can actually win
money by like you win apparently yeah yeah so so i thought
that was hilarious all right okay non-marvel rivals update
did you guys know not from Boston I felt like my whole world
fell apart when I found out that Canadians love naming
random beloved franchises over random places in fucking
America because I thought Boston pizza was a American brand
that just happened to be in that just was so popular that
they try they franchised out to Canada obviously people
enjoyed Boston pizza so now it's everywhere in Canada but
apparently no Boston pizza okay was invented by some fucking
guy in Edmonton because because it's not even it's not okay
the story is even crazy the guy called it Boston pizza not
because like he particularly like he was inspired by um um
but it was was like he was just like he was from it's not
because he was from Boston but the story of how like Boston
pizza was invented was because the founder who was from
Alberta went to Boston and then he tried a pizza there and
then it blew his mind so much like it was like he fucking
eat a random pizza in Boston that he was like I gotta start
a pizza restaurant and call Boston pizza as like as if like
it's like a fucking tribute to that one place that he ate
that fucking blew his mind I was just like no like he just
named it because he was like he had like his first East
Coast American pizza and he's like holy shit what the fuck
did I just ate and then you came back to Canada and I was
like I gotta start a restaurant and name it after Boston
like because he like hit Nirvana or some shit.
And then through that, because like people in America, like
my American fans were like, what the fuck is Boston pizza?
And I was like, what do you mean?
What the fuck is Boston pizza?
It's everywhere.
It's from Boston.
It's like it's a pizza made from Boston recipes.
Like, what do you mean?
And then I found out Boston pizza doesn't even exist in
America.
I was like what there's not even a reel in America it's just
it's just in Canada because apparently um
apparently um there's a thing that you guys have called
Boston Market and then um I read about Boston Market because
I was like what the fuck is Boston Market so that's
something that you guys actually have in America and the
thing about it is that Boston market cannot is illegal in
Canada because Boston pizza owns the trademark of Boston so
nothing in Canada can be have the name Boston in it because
um Boston pizza owns the trademark for it for the entirety
of Canada so they literally kicked up Boston market from
from Canada yeah we own We own the Boston pizza owns the
word Boston So American franchises whose name has Boston in
it is legally not allowed to be in Canada Yeah, so yeah,
because Boston market got sued by Boston pizza Because
they're like you're not allowed to call yourself Boston
Because we own the trademark of Boston here in Canada Which
is also fucking crazy.
And then, and then through that, I went, I was in a fucking
rabbit hole of numerous, I couldn't believe New York fries.
It is not, it's not New York fries.
I was like, you know what I mean?
The fries are not known in New York.
I thought New York was like well known for their fries.
Because we have a franchise called New York fries.
So then in my, it's literally a fast food franchise that's
known for just selling French fries.
Nothing else.
It's all just French fries, but it's different types of
French fries.
So I would assume, like I know it's crazy that they meant
when they were able to make a market of that, but it's
actually really fucking good.
And so I thought it was pizza and fries.
You know, it could be more than one.
It could be pizza and fries.
so in my head I thought New York had really fucking good
fries too because like in Canada we have New York fries and
then I found out New York fries was created by a Canadian as
well Canadians invented New York fries best poutine in
Canada I should have known when they're like they have
really good poutine as well but it's like um they're not
really yeah I I I should should have known when they also
specialize in poutine i was like americans don't know i was
like new york does not know anything about poutine um anyway
we also have swiss chalet which is a rotisserie and grill
nothing to do with swiss anything um is also owned by
canadians and then we also have i'm like looking through
this this tweet about like all this shit we also have
Apparently, I didn't even know about this barbecue place,
but apparently the biggest barbecue chain in Canada, because
I'm not really a fan of, um, I don't know, I've never like
really got, I don't really go to barbecue bars, but we also
have a barbecue chain called Montana's, uh, uh, I guess they
just, and Montana apparently is not known for barbecue, uh,
but it is our most famous, uh, it's our most famous, famous
barbecue chain in Canada um and then we also have St Louis
bar and grill which is known for their wings um but um but I
guess like it's also owned by Canadians as well St Louis is
owned by Canadians yeah I was just like holy fuck like I
don't know what like and then they become really famous too
like all the all these random canadian owned restaurants and
they're all like like all of them are just like randomly
named after american places like for no reason i don't
fucking know or swiss or swiss chalet um anyway but that's
the that's the life update i wanted to give you guys too oh
yeah also deadpool is voiced by saiyu who is our fellow of
vtuber by the way little tell it was really funny because
like when we saw the Deadpool preview everyone on Twitter
was like being like yeah that's Sayu like that that's him
that's him voicing um that's him voicing Deadpool and then
he was like guys I'm not Deadpool guys oh my god stop like
stop spreading this rumor I'm I'm not Deadpool and then he
like and then like you know the you know the official
announcement and he was like tiki guys oh my god guys oh who
would have thought i was the voice actor of dead full he's
like he's like no one will expect me to be dead full and
everyone was like bro we know we knew gabriel we fucking um
but yeah a fellow a fellow vtuber is technically in uh
marble rivals now i will say you guys might get really
annoyed when we try out deadpool because he does not shut up
like when i was pausing and checking my settings out he was
still talking so like it's like it's canon he's literally
very lore accurate but he does not stop talking even when
you're on the pause menu he will still keep talking because
like you guys were like ha ha that's so funny but if you
play this game a lot and if you're a Deadpool player and
you're like play him a lot it might get annoying very
quickly yeah it might because at one point he's just gonna
same lines over and over again so i don't know i don't know
how i'm gonna feel about it um so we'll see tomorrow i was
like i was like oh my god he doesn't stop talking like it's
just it's just non-stop yapping 24 7.
oh especially especially if you're on the losing side yeah
um so it's going to be interesting luckily like I don't
think I'll be able to I'll be playing Deadpool that much
overall so like it's not going to affect me but for people
who are like super competitive they might have a little bit
of a problem with it because I know like um um I know some
people who don't like that but like for me it doesn't really
matter to me because like um I also like I I don't one trick
a character but I feel like people who are like one tricks
might Or like, or just play the character a lot.
He is very strong.
Yeah.
Uh, he is, he seemed very, very strong.
You can't have three deadpulls on a team, sadly.
Um, you can't have three deadpulls on a team.
You can only have one deadpull, but that person can swap
between different deadpulls.
Um, I think you can't have three deadpulls on a team.
I don't know.
We, I got, we got to test it.
I don't actually, well, I can't test it out tomorrow anyway.
Um, that would be crazy if you can, because he seems really
fucking strong.
Imagine your team having three deadpulls.
That'll be crazy.
Anyway, it is God of War.
Okay, done yapping.
End up updates.
It's time to play God of War Ragnarok.
I need to adjust my sound settings real quick.
Let's see.
What did I write for this?
Bad.
uh let's boot up it's time it's time the game guys
he is definitely a yapper he's just like me for real for
real
but hey guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you but don't he that's basically you you won't stop yapping
i know he's just like me for real for real that's why that's
why it's gonna be fun he is very complicated um he's a very
very complicated character
oh i should have loaded in instead of press continue fuck um
i don't know if i'm getting better i'm still like i'm at
that place where like um i feel like i'm stuck in the
recovery phase right now that's like my only issue where am
i in my load should be this right oh my manual say what the
fuck is this grab that I feel like but I feel like I've been
stuck in like recovery right now the last three days I feel
like I'm not getting better or getting worse or just not not
so great yeah the lingering sickness I feel like it's been
lingering a lot wait what the fuck oh yeah that's that's bow
was being the key worked here little brother oh hey yeah
free stuff those stupid dwarves leaving out good shit out
there for me to take just reinforcing their prejudice
against us like this is why we don't let the intruders in
all right let's wink mine now shouldn't have fucking left
your door open Here we go.
Alright.
Yeah.
Alright, I guess we go down here.
Maybe there's a boat we can use to get to Darlene's.
Oh yeah, I saw some people talking about like what the
brainstorm stream ideas are.
It's not worth to suggest like games for me to play.
It's more like coming up with like creative streams
together.
So I was like literally, I was like watching Doug Doug
recently.
I mean, I watched him like on and off, but I would like
rewatch some of like I was just like checking his channel
out again after having having watched him for like a year
it's like stuff like that like creative streams not like oh
can you play x game or can you play this game it's more so
like don't get back to my creative side like I have some
stuff written down um for like some fun things written down
that we could do in the future but it's like those type of
creative streams that i'm thinking of yeah all right we go
this way actually i i hit up like a programmer to see if
they could create us like a a chat integrate integration
game like dug dug where i do like a battle royale in chat
because it's i was inspired by dug doug's um um dug doug's
what was it rock paper scissors battle royale and i was like
i want to do something like that were you guys because it
would be fun watching you guys fight each other i was like i
want to watch you fight and then one of the video and one of
the like stuff he did he was like um he was like all right
guys vote for a person you want to kill off and then they're
like oh jk guys the person you voted is actually gonna get a
knife now you with the knife you have to kill someone in
chat right now i'm like oh i like that that's so sadistic
that's so fucking fun i want to give i want to give you to
see you guys see the smoke stacks from here but if you don't
want to and it's like all right chat defend yourself say why
explain why you should
Lord Kurosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You could make cute food stream.
Dragons love that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, my God.
This area?
We could prepare more before rest.
I feel like God of war.
Also, I was like being super.
Oh, I see what he says.
I should interrupt the dialogue.
This might be important.
docky who the fuck are you oh my god there's so much stuff
to do here there's a lot bigger than um there's no yeah
there's a lot bigger than the first uh not first one but
last god of war were you doing side quest i don't know i'm
just rolling my boat what do i want to say oh i lost my
train of thought before i uh i was like listening to that oh
that's Wait, is that a dragon?
What is that?
Oh, it's a dead dragon.
Wait, isn't there a squirrel here by Prod-Z?
That dragon sculpture is not bad.
I don't think it's a dragon.
I think it's a actual dead dragon.
Oh, this sculpture.
What was I talking about before?
I had a train of thought.
I forgot about it.
Alright, nope.
I'm gonna kill you though Wait, I gotta swap to do it Oh
shit, it has to be ice Oh shit, sorry I just gotta remember
how to play this game Oh my god, stop I don't remember
Oh my god Okay, bro, fuck these guys Actually, fuck these
guys I fucking, oh my god Like, I hate this I can't Get me
now if I have my shield.
There we go.
Alright, there we go.
How do I dodge again?
Wait, oh, it's X.
Okay.
Don't worry, I have my shield.
Okay, we gotta kill you, though.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
All right, are they all dead?
They're all dead.
Okay.
Well, fuck that specific rock too Fuck that one rock in
particular.
Oh, they're not all dead.
That's fine They will be There we go now they're all dead.
Oh, never mind one more guy one more guy for the ride All
right, shoot him Sorry, I have to remember how to play the
game.
I literally forgot, but...
When I have, like, too many games I'm playing, I forget.
Oh, I remember my train of thought.
I don't know why.
I got, like, super, like...
What's the word?
I got, like, super anal about, like...
Because I was like, oh, shit, am I...
Do I look too big on the screen?
So I did make myself a little smaller.
I don't know why I got like these random phases this hyper
fixations where I'm like oh do I look too big on the screen
oh I just I hope I'm not covering up myself covering up the
game too much so I made myself a little bit smaller I don't
know I was like literally for three hours last night last
night and like the last couple of oh wait no um wait why
can't I rob you you're dead I deserve
alive I thought the boss music stopped all
right well I guess I can't take this fucking thing but yeah
no I was like right after the right after the Metal Gear
stream I had like a weird hype oh my god there you are I
knew it I knew you were hiding somewhere you fucking bitch
all right there we go i knew there was one more guy i
couldn't rob this dead lady and then like like he was just
sitting there he wasn't even moving that was the worst part
let's just all right don't worry arteus look i can read
someone's told me that never mind never mind i still can't
read but like like it was weird i got like in a really weird
like hyper fixation about like how big i am on the screen i
might be make myself smaller in the future.
Oh my god.
No!
My free money!
Oh wait, wait.
I've got it.
I got this.
Arteus, this is it's up to you.
Alright.
Wait, does this does he hit him?
No, he doesn't.
Wait.
Like every stream I just make myself smaller and smaller.
Every stream I just happen to make myself smaller and
smaller and smaller until I'm teeny tiny I know but I can't
go there's does he come spawn from behind me no he doesn't
so what the fuck do I do but
like I got really like hyper fixated on that because I'm
always worried about like if I'm covering up the screen too
much and shit like that.
So then I was like literally like looking back and forth the
last three days being like, oh, am I too big on the screen?
Do I cover too much stuff?
I think we need some special equipment to use this.
Special equipment?
You mean not your goddamn arrows?
Yeah.
Guys, who's that amazing character on the bottom right of
the screen?
She looks kind of cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Jay, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm just going to shoot that.
That's it.
All right.
I don't know.
I'm weird like that.
I just always want to make sure that you guys are getting
the best experience possible.
I mean, we're recovering the third.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm like.
Oh, should I be smaller?
or is it or like is it better is it okay because I figure I
was like re-watching the God of Warstream and I was like oh
I feel like I'm too big
alright let's see there is a blue mark here okay where the
fuck is it
I think it's fun wait you do?
What do you see?
What do you see with your special eyes?
How do I fucking kill this rodent?
Like, it's like behind him, but I can't go behind him.
It's... No!
No horses!
I will kill off all the horses in this land.
No!
I will prevent the prophecy.
It's like that guy who, like, who tried to kill off all the
sons or some shit.
Because his, like, um, because, like, in the prophecy, he,
uh, his son was going to kill him.
And then in the end, um, one, one of his sons, um, managed
to escape.
And his son fucked his mom because he wasn't, he didn't
know.
And then fulfilled the prophecy of killing his dad.
Also, yeah, Oedipus.
Yeah, and then also banged his mom.
It's like, you can't stop fate.
Where do I go?
Like, there's like three things here, but I don't see any of
the things for me to whack.
Climb up and look down in the hole.
Okay.
all right
happy year of the horse oh yeah it's the year of the horse
too fun stop thank you the super chat thank you thank you
the best possible viewer experience is 95% uh wait maybe
here oh there we go there's the hole I see it I see the hole
where there's a hole there's a goal All right, you want to
come on now?
Eating.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Well, we got that.
I guess we don't get this because I don't know where it is.
I don't see any of the blue stuff.
Arteus, do you see any of the good shit?
The blue shit?
Arteus?
oh yeah i forgot i wanted to adjust the volume you're right
let me boost it up a little i do if we're boosting this up i
do think we should lower the audio a little bit uh i'll read
this and then put that in yeah
freeze the water oh there's this water Where does this go?
Oh!
Whoa, I see.
But like, that doesn't do anything anyway.
Oh!
I see.
Oh, clever!
Clever, clever.
Alright.
Okay, um...
okay okay arteus i need to shoot it okay how the fuck arteus
can you shoot it how the fuck do i shoot that oh here okay
there we go oh my god wait these these are like harder
because it's like they're not like glowing in a way okay
they are they're okay but like They're not, like, super
glowing.
They're, like, less obvious than before.
Oh, I had an apple.
An apple.
Oh, I need two.
I guess two apples.
Two apples a day.
They change from one to two.
Oh, that's another boat.
Oh, my God.
There's boat-free days.
Yay.
Yeah.
i can see why this game can be really long so not all
dwarves can do that thing brock and cindry do right not all
dwarves arteus don't be racist i gather one carefully
cultivated by some secret of dwarven guild or other probably
for the best them alone doing it is disconcerting enough
everyone has their own skills arteus not all dwarves are
good at armory we need dwarves who can count money and wars
who can farm.
How else would they eat, Arteus?
Think.
Think with your brain.
It's a society.
Oh, yeah.
Taking a break before visiting Dirlin?
Very wise.
He can be a lot.
What's in here?
Oh, this is my secret... Oh, never mind.
I thought it was my secret.
It seems useful.
Alright, let's go craft some shit real quick.
uh all right i forgot to ask you guys like is it is there
any point in upgrading my handle stuff or do i save it i
feel like i should just or and also the shield i didn't rob
him he saved it for me is there any point in upgrading the
handle stuff or like uh the armor or should i just save all
right guys what armor do I do I just can I try gives this
upgrade from this armor or save up oh wait this one's better
it's level 2 all upgrades are important well equip this
oh okay i think this one is still stronger though i use
rider all the way to end game this one not that that i'll do
upgrade my i'll disinfect my tools if this is anything like
the first thing anything that proves your level is good
because that's the most important stat okay you're right i
should get swole that's the most important part what about
my shield is it worth uh is it worth uh upgrading my shield
or will i get better shields later
he's embarrassed okay he's embarrassed about his nipples
there's better shields yes and okay that does not that is
sad of all right i'll upgrade the godless shields for now
all right and then i'll by the way if you're headed to the
mining rigs in the bay could you bring me any slag you find
what the is that oh all right let's let me re-equip my stuff
that's okay we don't care about you boy it's all about me me
me me oh wait what why can't i wear the oh was it craft item
that crafted yet okay wait whatever you need I thought
crowds they already have it crafted why can't I wear I can't
wear this wait
what can I fucking wear this that's my armor minus waste guy
to you yeah I don't own it I'm confused oh Oh, I need more
of the ore.
Oh, okay.
I thought I already owned it.
I was like, where is it in my inventory?
All right, then we don't care.
I don't care, but...
Oh, nice.
I see it and I hammer.
What the fuck is this?
all right go up go up boy
yeah but i thought like it was just for upgrades i didn't
realize if it was for crafting as like crafting the armor
that i don't have
oh knock knock oh never mind still here what what is it near
the geyser we need to get the key from it and unlock this
door Okay.
I need to set right a very old wrong.
Oh shit.
Were you a bully?
Boss fight.
Oh it's okay.
It just got our taste.
Wait I can.
Fucking random ass boss fight in the middle of nowhere.
That's alright.
I'll beat him up.
I fucking run!
Get down!
damn boy i'm gonna show you how it's oh my god there's more
oh my god okay i did not realize there was more um oh god oh
god i'm on fire but you probably already know that it's okay
yeah no shit boy oh that's not fair being third-party all
right Oh my god.
Fucking random ass guy here.
There you go.
Oh my god, there you go.
It's fine.
Oh shit, it's fine.
Oh my god, it's so...
Oh, it's not fun!
It's no longer fun!
Oh my god, oh my god.
No!
No, no, no, no, no!
Okay, oh my god.
My god, my god, my god, I'm not even close.
Not even close.
So easy.
All right, didn't even panic at all.
Look at that.
God.
God, gaming is so easy when you're dokeybird.
Zero sweat.
Oh, shit.
He sent in the prison.
Odin's ravens over here.
We're not gonna find all of them.
It's fine.
Like, it was like 40 plus ravens.
And I have fair things to do.
I know we won't find them.
all 40 of them see the smoke above us that's where we're
headed let's see if we can't shut it down
all right just let him hate just let the man hate let him
watch if he wants to
oh all right it's fine It's poison from above.
It's fine.
Boom!
Why are you hitting yourself, huh?
That's fucking right.
Alright, there's this guy over here.
Get over here.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
That's where's my axe.
I hate it.
Whoops.
Easy.
Alright, who did that?
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, my.
God, guys, please, one at a time.
There's plenty of dad going everywhere.
Jesus Christ, that's a lot.
There's enough dad to go around.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's what he meant.
Because I was like, what do you mean?
I dodged.
Did I not?
Oh, my God.
Get this flying creature out of here.
for you fucking cheater just cuz you can fly so many enemies
holy shit that's fucking right there's so many there's more
enemies in the last game for sure I think is that all
there's more Jesus.
Incoming!
Alright, oh there you go.
The rings likely chock a block with materials that could
help us.
I'd grab whatever it spits up in the process.
Alright, let's grab some HP.
Oh, wait, that's not where I want to go.
Bring me down.
Alright, nice.
Reload.
What do I do here?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
No more smoke.
Oh, it's the mining rigs I shut down.
Oh, that's why.
I talk to them to their own exploitation.
They need their choice.
Work or die is not a choice.
I only made it seem so.
What you just picked up there is pure, Spartal fight war.
It won't be of use in the rig anymore, but perhaps our
Holder brothers could craft something from it.
Okay.
We need, like, two more of that.
Okay, so we do more of the mining stuff.
Then we'll be able to craft the other armor that we saw.
That was the armor, right?
Bro, the George and Rala above capitalism.
What do you mean?
That's literally their whole shick.
all right i don't remember how united oh wait is that united
okay um l2r2 l2r2 there we go i did it so hard oh my god i
could use that
And a two are two!
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
The bomb.
Okay, how?
How?
Oh my god, I swear to you guys, I go up here.
And then...
How the fuck do I...
Okay, wait, wait, I figured it out.
There you go.
Are you fucking... Okay.
There we go.
L2R2.
Okay, we're missing one more.
Where is the last L2R2?
Where is it?
Where is it hiding?
Those two are two?
Where are you hiding?
What the fuck?
I don't see anymore.
It's over there.
Did you see it?
And I'll come out wherever you are.
There's breaking random jars.
I literally don't see any more pots.
Hello?
Pots?
I'm gonna break that jar for now.
Fuck that jar.
Oh.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, it's nothing.
Over there.
Over where?
Where the fuck is this jar?
It's a jar.
here there's no way the bear is there's bears oh these bears
over these bears oh my god the fucking stupid ass bears okay
there we go now give me my loot.
I earned it.
Yeah!
Okay, I need one or two.
God, these guys are so stingy.
You would think like apples are so easy to get here.
They're all about them apples.
Is that pure Spartle-fine slag?
Give it here.
What does he make for us if I give it to him?
I'll heat up the forest.
is it from this oh it is ah i see doesn't give me stronger
okay i'll i'll get that one the wrist arm oh okay wait it's
just defense oh no that's strength i like that huh that
might be my best piece yet today oh i can upgrade too we'll
grab that upgrade then a good fit all right
Take care of your armor and it'll take care of you I'm
already lost.
I don't know where I've been and where I haven't been We
visited two places.
I'm like where do I go now?
I'll go to the other rig right here.
Oh wait, there's a key right here.
You think shutting these things down will help the dwarfs
become independent?
I don't know but I have to try something He did say there is
an island near the geyser that has a key
Should be like this island, right?
That's the key island.
Yeah, I'm still sick.
I'm unfortunately still sick, but I'm taking it.
Oh my god, not the stupid fucking lizards.
Get out of here.
here.
Oh my god, we gotta destroy the nest.
We gotta destroy his home.
We gotta get his home.
We will make you an extinct species.
They're an invasive species.
We gotta let him go.
Alright, where do I go now?
Shoot the pot.
Never mind.
I got a giant axe.
Okay, for this way down I didn't orphan those lizards I
killed the orphans so that makes it better they're not
orphans anymore you're welcome okay there's another one
where's the other nest the ground looks weak down here
father okay let's push this up first oh we do that and then
we push this up oh guess not oh there we go that gear let's
take it with freeze then we do this maybe that lift can help
us get high might be easier to break that ground from up
What?
Oh, from here.
Alright, up I go.
Yeah!
Okay, and then...
Get my axe back.
And then...
Watch this.
Oh!
Okay, sorry.
Just testing it out.
I had to see how fire...
Yeah, I can.
That's right.
Oh, my Okay.
Oh my god.
Any fucking spits losers out.
I'm fucking course.
I'm just gonna beat him up.
That's fucking right.
Oh my god.
No, not the child.
We're here to beat up mama.
Mama time.
We gotta beat up the mom.
Okay.
That's okay.
He's just sending out more kids.
But they do not matter to me.
That's fucking right.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, that's stupid, goddamn...
Alright, that's it!
Fist to fist!
Get out of here!
Okay, now that they're orphans, we'll make sure there's no
witnesses.
Alright, now there's no orphans.
Look at that.
Isn't that beautiful?
Life is beautiful, the circle of life.
Alright, let's see.
The key should be here.
Is that the key?
That's the key.
Oh, there you go.
Now we must head to that watchtower on the shore.
Nature is beautiful, guys.
I just need you to trust me.
All right, so where is the watchtower?
Is it there?
I think it was there.
It was like here, right?
I'm already lost.
Do I have a map?
Oh, I do.
Okay.
I was gonna say, oh, that's not helpful because I don't
remember how I got there.
I, I, oh, I should have, oh, I should have looked this up.
Okay, I'll just go this way first.
Amir, how many stories have you told about Odin and Thor and
all the bad things they've done?
Let's see how many we can remember.
Seems like Father could use his memory refreshed.
is no refreshment okay and then from here i'm talking about
history all the other people they've heard let's see where
did i where is this prison uh how did i get here oh okay so
oh go back okay go back back to thor notan stories where
were we enough We will continue later.
Here.
And then...
Oh, oh, I remember now.
I remember.
It's up here.
Yeah, see, guys?
I remember.
And then here.
And then it's not here.
It's here.
I lost the 50-50.
But I remember now.
I remember, guys.
It's here.
And then we go...
Oh, I can't go up from here.
We go up here.
See, I told you guys I remember.
It was just the opposite of what I remember.
No.
Thought I heard a voice.
Let's keep going live.
I opened the jail.
Yeah, my memory's just mirrored right now.
Knock, knock.
Yeah.
You could give that drum a good loud strike.
Oh, okay.
I guess it's a cutscene strike.
Oh.
Where is he?
Yeah, my controller was inverted, guys.
That's why I got...
I hit the wrong thing.
What?
So that's the voice I heard.
I'd hoped it would have escaped my narrative.
We'll need to free it from its restraints.
Oh, that's a big-ass turtle!
Oh, shit.
That's a turtle.
Oh, that's a whale.
That's not a turtle.
That's a...
That's...
Because that's a whale.
Wait.
Oh, I can't use my weapon when I'm on the boat.
Hello.
Where are your restraints?
Sir?
What is this?
A loon boker.
I captured it.
A few years ago.
Crowden.
Yes.
an imaginative eye catching yeah i don't think like i don't
think he should work he should live here what a cool turtle
all right so obviously this is it's like seaworld yeah we're
free willying it it's literally free willy i assume we have
to be on this area yeah it's free willy no thank you for the
super chat they can thank you free will yeah this creature
you enslaved it i but why because i was young and stupid and
i didn't know what it was like to be chained in one place
for a year with nothing to occupy your mind but pain i knew
it i don't did not trust that i knew it i knew that Shit
ain't real.
Let's chop that up.
I keep forgetting that you don't even get immunity for this
shit.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Chop!
Get out of here!
There you go.
God, that's so easy.
Bam.
Yeah, you see that?
Get out of here!
Get out of here, too.
Yeah, chop, chop.
Alright, let's see.
Where do we go?
Let's grab...
Let's shoot full HP just for now.
Just for the sake of it.
Uh.
all right right here oh there you go first restraint gotta
cut this off
yeah oh that's gotta oh shit that's like embedded on him too
all right that's good it's nice that he knows
all right we gotta go to the other side that creature's
hurting but we're going to free it but it will always be
changed you know okay how is he gonna get out of here first
off i don't is he ideal isn't this a lake
like where did he come from
yeah that's that's something we'll let future kratos worry
about remember the feeling of a yoke around my neck i would
not wish it upon another yeah i was like i don't think this
is his natural habitat
uh oh time to read well that future crate i was worried
about that
remove our resources always wear earplugs I guess I never
learned how to read
Yeah, up I go What's down there?
Can I even chop anything down there?
Nah They're supposed to go up here Oh my god, there's so
many places to explore It's so overwhelming Oh Five forage
iron.
Yay!
Oh god, they're dead.
More grave robbing.
My favorite part.
Okay.
Oh, shit, okay.
Oh, dang god.
Okay, I thought I was gonna die.
Oh, oh.
I guess I'm here now.
It's like, okay.
I guess I'll be here.
Oh, free... Oh, free money.
I'll take it.
Yeah, they won't need it.
They're dead.
I wish there was, like, fast travel, like, fast lie.
Where the fuck is the last restraint?
That's fucking right.
shit wait there's more all right cut this guy's cut this guy
in half first i'll do that oh oh my god father's son bonding
time right here
oh and get him out yeah we did it why enslave the creature
it's fat was a good source of oil
oil for lanterns whatever anger you're feeling whatever
loathing toward me yeah all for oil
that's crazy all that for oil yeah i'm still sick i think
it's gonna be a while i always get it always takes a while
for me to recover which sucks because like i view things
have to record but um like you know there's nothing i could
do about it
just the tail left now okay just the tail okay but i want to
go here what oh all the lasers i was like what's hitting you
what How the fuck did I get over here?
Oh my god, these goddamn stupid lizards.
Oh my god, this house.
I did not notice that.
Don't worry.
We're going to get rid of your house now.
Oh.
Oh, R bombs.
L2.
Oh, okay.
Alright, now I know how to get it, though.
Alright, there we go.
And then...
I open the shortcut.
Yay!
Wee!
Okay, there is one more over there.
I'll hide.
I guess I carry this.
And...
I mean, how long can I hold it for?
Okay, okay.
I don't know if, like, I need to...
I can use that.
But we'll try again.
I didn't know there was fall off, guys.
I don't know.
I big, strong arms did not realize I would not fucking chuck
it like a baseball.
Maybe that dock can lead us to the tail.
Okay.
Let's get back to the boat.
Yeah, I don't think Kratos is going to do anything with
baseball anytime soon.
Does that surprise you?
That an old man would be ashamed of the mistakes he's made.
No.
I thought...
I'd hoped the creature would be long expired by now.
But apparently the ACR couldn't use it.
be bothered to mercy kill it once it was no longer useful uh
we could kill it what no not when we can save it bro he's
like so healthy i was like he's like don't hey guys i'm fine
no don't we just need to kill him it's like guys look i'm
i'm all better now everything is okay he's like no he's
suffering look at him you would still save this broken
creature i know what it is to be imprisoned like this i
can't just leave it and if it is beyond saving i don't
understand let us continue all right hell yeah
yeah i don't trust it i knew it i knew you were alive
fucking plague dead behind you look out Fucking knew they
were playing dead.
Oh, shit, I could chop them so early.
It was, like, not even...
Well, okay, grab, grab how.
Oh, shit, I did not mean to do that, but that's fine.
Overkill time.
Fuck that one guy in particular.
Alright.
We'll just...
That's fine.
I'll just use my fist.
Okay, he's definitely dead.
Yeah, I was like, oh yeah, no, he's off the cliff.
I don't need to do anything else after that.
Again?
How you still am not?
Oh my god, there's a lot.
Never mind.
There is a lot.
There is a lot of them.
Okay, I was not expecting all of these guys.
I fucking know.
Oh my god, my axe.
I just fucking chucked that out.
Oh my god, they're always behind me!
Where's the last guy?
Get out of here.
Alright, they're all dead.
We're fine.
See?
I got my HP again.
It's like nothing bad ever happened.
Okay.
this guy.
Did you check behind you?
How about I cut it?
Oh, I was all the way down there.
Alright, but first, let me explore.
Don't worry, I'll be back.
Don't worry, you'll be free soon.
Just want a little bit of loot.
A little bit of loot.
and hurt nobody.
Howard, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Saw you were on the big screen before I was trying to go and
any plans on visiting SCA, AnnieCon again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, I don't know.
It's, uh, I don't, for events and stuff, my event staff
handles most of it.
And I just say yes or no.
But I would love to.
I'd love to come back to more Southeast Asia cons.
I always love visiting dragons from around the world.
I'm going to be as many dragons as possible from around the
world.
Happy birthday!
Oh!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Howard.
there i think i see something oh is there a bomb back there
oh my god i get the bomb oh my god i can't go back no no
there you're free free with him okay but what about this
rope thing what's going on yeah what He's not, he's like,
nope.
That was gonna say, I don't think he doesn't want to go.
What's this?
Yeah, I don't think we can do anything with that yet.
Boy, I paid for your education and you can't do anything
about it.
What's the point?
I sent you to Magic College and you didn't learn anything.
This creature, the mining rigs, their mistakes, Amir.
But it's Odin's fault.
That's not an excuse, little one.
But thank you for seeing it.
Wait, was there...
Treasure?
Oh yeah, he was homeschooled.
Boy, I homeschooled you when you're there, nothing?
Oh, yeah, apparently, like...
Um...
asked me if I was in Sapporo.
And I was like, no.
Because I was going to be in Japan anyway for...
What treasure?
You guys lied to me.
I got all the treasure.
Anyway, for the Street Fighter thing.
So I was just like...
The other way?
What do you mean the other way?
I got all the treasure.
See?
I'm going to go back to the whale now.
Oh, you mean the treasure?
I left from when I actually went down.
Apparently, though, they had a snowstorm in Sapporo.
So a lot of flights got canceled and stuff.
Well, there you have it, lad.
That's scary.
That's always scary.
A snowstorm, too.
Like, flying into, like, doing a long flight in the middle
of a snowstorm.
But, yeah, apparently, like, a lot of flights got canceled
to Sapporo.
So some people might not make it on day one of land.
Like those who are like bootcamping, bootcamping on like out
of like different countries.
Apparently some players might not even like make it to like
the first day, which is crazy.
Oh, it's explosive here.
What is the shortcut for?
I don't remember where this is.
Where is the circuit?
Oh, wait.
I'm lost.
I'm always lost.
Oh, to my right?
This is my right.
Yeah, but I can't explode that.
I need to find the explosive.
I hear it.
Oh my god, I hear the...
Where is it?
Through this door?
Oh, there it is.
I fucking knew I heard it.
Alright, let's get rid of this one first.
Because I realized there is more loot.
here yeah I remember this area there you go yeah yeah and
the way it's like free me you know that yeah don't worry
well we'll free you soon we just gotta take all your money
first.
Okay, this one.
And then...
I mean, he's been in prison for hundreds of years.
He can be in prison for, like, five more minutes.
Alright.
I missed a hole?
Well, we all know if there's a hole.
Where's the hole?
Yeah?
Is there a hole here that I missed?
Oh, there was!
There is a goal!
Oh, that is secret.
Secret, don't know.
So much loot.
Oh, hey.
Stupid crow.
Yeah, we're not getting a 48 of these guys.
There's no point.
No, that's all right.
If Oden wants to watch, he can watch.
I'm fine with that.
Yeah.
Goodbye.
I knew Kroki was a double agent.
Wait.
Yeah, it's here.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, wait, it was not out yet.
Wait a minute.
Give me a sec.
Okay, it's down here.
Okay, I got lost in the sauce.
This way.
And then...
Uh...
This way.
Knew it.
And then where's my boat?
And then...
Wait, where the fuck?
is my boat wait do i have a boat here i do not have a boat
here you are getting better faster i'd even be better than
you one day huh oh whoa calm down calm down you are not
gonna kill your old man yet calm the down
yeah i'm i'm odin's twitch stream right now i'm his favorite
twitch streamer Our crow streamer on crow.tv.
All right, now we can talk to the eye.
All right, that's his tail.
So his eye should be up here.
What other terrible things have Odin and Thor done?
Okay.
There was Thaumor, the stone mason.
Hi.
He quarreled with his son.
Went into the night to find him.
Found Thor instead.
And there was Thaumor's son.
Oh, he only has one.
God.
And whispered something of importance to Freya before his
betrayal and assassination.
How's the audio so far?
You guys hear them?
Thor murdered her husband and Odin covered it up before
doing her in himself.
You can't forget Amir.
The first giant.
Odin carved him up to form the realms from his body and let
the torrent of his blood nearly drown every giant alive.
What about the giants of Yodenhunt?
They all seem dead when we finally made it there.
That remains a mystery.
Though admittedly, it sounds like the Asiore god's dream.
What about Fjordian?
Thor's mother was a giant.
Wasn't she?
Indeed she was.
The circumstances of her demise were murky at best.
But not sure I can blame Odin for that one.
He wasn't the same after.
Oh, I know.
There was Skavi, the queen of the hunt.
I, she spurned Odin's affections.
So we tricked her into killing her father.
Gather the mighty.
The Yotenar military leader.
Slandered by Odin.
Tricked and murdered by Thor.
Are these all the ladies?
He banged?
The giant king who stole Thor's hand.
Oh no, all the people he was killed.
Odin traded him free to get it back.
And sent Thor in disguise to murder his entire corpse.
Oh, fuck, bro.
Groom near the brawler.
The stone giant.
I.
Mocked by Odin.
Murdered by Thor.
Enough of this.
But there's more.
I do not care.
There's fucking hitless.
Crazy.
Is not the answer.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One fact about Odin's ravening.
There are sacrifice children.
So you're committing...
Oh!
No, I'm committing murder.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Get it, right Warren?
It's not abuse, it's murder.
Come here.
What do you think it means?
Seeing more raiders come back as Hellwalkers lately.
I thought freeing the Valkyrie Queen was supposed to restore
balance to the realms and keep that from happening That's a
good question lad and a troubling one If hell's filled up
again, it suggests that something's been hindering Siegren's
efforts Or perhaps something even more urgent is keeping her
distracted Unable to visit even occasionally.
Yeah.
Sorry, Namir.
All right It's time to talk to him Okay Go talk to your
whale girlfriend
Go on you great blubbering beast This is free willy go on
Why is it not moving?
Custom do its change.
Oh No, no, we can fix this.
We just need to chase it off and scare it Go we didn't love
you anyways like the ash catch on with butterfree go We hate
you Oh, he better than they were.
He likes the wind blowing on its face.
I can feel it.
That's why he stayed?
That's not enough.
It seldom is.
He's like, I like the wind.
Bro, bro, this is, it's like putting a goldfish in a
fucking, like those like circle, like mini-ass goldfish
tanks.
There's nowhere to swim, bro.
You're literally trapped in seaworld.
I don't think I freed him, but okay.
I guess stay willy?
Yeah, it's like putting the goldfish in a fish book.
And put Never Spear Rines with the Book Captain.
Okay.
It's not even free willy anymore.
It's stay willy.
what is it lamia that's nothing brother just you ever have
those moments where you wish you could go back rewrite your
own past enough we will continue oh man i didn't know that
he only talks when he's on the boat smell that smoke why
would the dwarves agree to work for the ace here in the
first place that's the heart of it eh you lied to them i
lied to them All right.
Bet we could swing across that uh lift thing.
Gantry.
Where's the...
Oh, okay, so I don't have to, I don't have to chain it.
That's good to know.
All right, grab the money real quick.
Can I break that?
No.
Is there anything up here?
Okay.
Not quite right.
No?
What?
Why is there no sound?
Wait.
Oh, wait, it's bugged.
Do you guys notice that?
There's no sound effects.
Yeah.
He's just...
Yeah, he's just grunting.
It's like It's gotta be the right spot Like this has sound
effects But moving does it
Those bottles I smell fuel Bet a spot from your blades Would
cause quite a boom Oh it's not shit
Oh Yeah like there's certain items yeah it's like grunting
asmr right now
okay they're so weird
it's literally just grunting asmr you can break through the
ground here if you found a high enough place to drop from i
think i don't know what to do reload save and might fix it
but like where will it take me though if I reload the save
wait if I didn't fix it right no I don't know I was like
wondering why I felt so off I feel like I reload the save I
don't know where it's gonna take me
all right save and reload should I do try it I'll try it
it saves at every boat dock okay let's see zoom in this one.
Is it?
What time is it?
Yeah.
I was like wondering why I was like, she's grunting awfully
lot right now.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Now it sounds like we're gaming now.
I was like, damn, that's a lot of grunting.
I think we could break through the ground here if you found
a high enough place to drop from.
Alright.
It fixed itself.
We go up here.
Oh my god, one of them isn't real.
I know it.
There's too many baits.
I know one of you ain't real.
I think I'm missing back there, though.
No, I have to go there.
this way okay nice
okay I can see why this game is 20 to 30 hours now there's a
lot of places to explore shut these rigs off themselves why
not you tried the ain't her yard made examples of them they
killed the dwarves can you have convince them not to I
because I'm like oh did I miss anything did I oh my gosh did
I miss any loot there was I supposed to go here or was this
the like is this the optional way or is a mandatory way
that's fucking right I should be able to upgrade right now
oh my god forgot about the upgrade feature
I have not upgraded at all In a long ass time Um, I'll
upgrade my axe I'm gonna use I've been using it a lot Let's
see Yeah, we need Do we not?
Yeah, we need this Oh, yeah, I'm fucking rich as hell right
now
Okay, we get that
Hold it for a bro that throws the enemy Weaker throws Oh!
I like the sound of that Funny man.
I mean, I could technically upgrade everything.
Yeah, I'm fucking...
I had too much stuff.
I was not paying attention.
Alright, let's see.
Arteus.
Yes, please draw pressure on you to do aggro.
Alright, that makes more sense.
Yeah, but aren't we against, like, ice people?
Where did it make more sense to use my ice?
My axe against these guys?
Huh?
Impressive.
How do I get over here?
Oh, I have to lower the...
Lower it.
Wait, I'm sorry.
I mean, aren't they like five people?
Oh, hey, there's a turtle.
I'm like, there's a turtle.
Chop, chop.
Wait, that was nothing.
I thought there was loot.
I thought, like, it's progression.
Where do I go?
I'm a little lost now.
Just a little bit.
Oh!
Wait, I got it.
I figured it out.
Okay, we put it down here so we can get loot.
I'm so smart.
Fucking knew it.
Okay, and then from here, we raised it all the way up.
See?
I'm smart.
And then from here...
We raise it all the way up.
Like here.
Uh, maybe that's two up.
Is that two up?
No, from here.
Yeah.
And then...
We...
Go this way.
How do we get it from this way?
Guys, I don't think this is it.
I think that's two up.
I think...
Guys, I think that was a little two up, guys.
Oh my god, it's not even, like...
I don't even, like, get to go there.
What?
Where would it go?
Don't go.
Alright, I guess...
Yeah, that might be a little two up.
as we go one down
two upies there's such a thing as two upies what a world we
live in no
what do i do no it is a piece no we have to do it is a
Please.
We have to figure out how to!
Oh my god.
I'm so bad with puzzles.
Fuck this one bird in particular.
Fuck this bird.
I'm angry now.
I shall let my anger out on this bird.
Like, what did this bird do to me?
I don't care.
Oh, wait, wait.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Oh, I figured it out!
So what we do is we lower it down and then and then this...
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We go up here.
Okay.
Okay, that is further than I expected.
Um.
Hmm.
Okay.
Um.
Wait, give me a sec.
Oh, oh, oh, I figured it out.
out we push it back up and then okay look see i i just
didn't look everywhere guys i made a mistake and then we go
up here and then i told you i figured it out yeah but so it
wasn't so hard yeah see it wasn't so hard wait what's okay
we gotta put this down here
Or then we go back up.
See, it wasn't so high.
All right, activate this stupid boss, but...
All right.
What the?!
Okay, bro, okay, okay, okay, just... I said... I thought he
was supposed to aggro this.
That's fine.
Get your ass over here.
That's right.
Slab dunk tab.
Slab dunk!
Okay.
Oh, okay, that was sick.
All right, that should be everything.
All right, get this oil.
Oh, sorry, milling.
I'm not sorry.
Mining.
Three times the charm.
I figured out what it is.
Get this mine rig out of here.
Oh, I got there eventually.
To the blacksmiths of Svartalfine, the creation of a weapon
was a sacred thing.
But Odin just wanted as many blades as he could get, as fast
as he could get them.
With every stolen resource and mediocre blade, the dwarves
lost a bit of themselves.
Don't worry, we'll free them.
Alright.
No more mining for you.
I'll free these dwarves.
I'll free them from mining.
Then they could chase their real dreams.
Whatever they are.
Okay, but what the fuck is that up there though?
Like, up here there's like another thing we could do.
Like this.
seem like we can reach it from down here okay maybe i turn
it up once more the dwarf survived because of you yeah
they're real dreams odin would have wiped out every last
dwarf and sparkle flame if he couldn't use their skills no
one could yeah what if they just want to dance and odin was
like no dancing in my realm Maybe up here, I can do it.
Yeah, because I'm like, obviously there's something here.
How do I get across from that?
Oh, here it is.
Alright.
I knew it.
My exploration senses were tingling.
There you go.
Yeah!
Loot!
Oh, nice.
Where's the loot?
Wait, this is not the loot.
Oh, there it is.
There's my loot.
Oh, nice.
I got runic.
Alright, we can leave now.
Boy.
Boy!
We can go!
Alright.
Off to another mining rig.
For more loot.
oh your teeth is up that that that is not healthy for a
whale oh used as wisdom and might to imprison some of the
most dangerous creatures and all that we gotta send this
whale to a dentist what is a little tunnel hello little
tunnel Yeah, we gotta call a dentist for that guy.
That is not healthy teeth right there.
One more mining ring.
Since that cranks the worst.
We'll crank.
Oh, barrel.
Yeah, there's no plankton for him.
To help with his teeth.
smell the smoke there's another mining rig here you speak of
your deeds with shame do you regret not allowing Odin to
kill them are doing oh my god they're fire I was like don't
worry I shall fight fire with fire I don't get it the doors
weren't chained up like the Lumbacher couldn't they quit and
do what their newly built fortress poisoned the spot on
unable to grow their own food they had to buy it from asgard
oh they'd be taking food out of their own mouths yeah that's
clever and awful yeah they fucked up have they ever thought
about moving yeah just just move somewhere else it's just
that easy guys just just move I love that they're like,
you're like, I hate living here.
And then people would be like, why are you used to live
here?
You know, just move.
And then people are like, yeah, but what about mortgages and
house paying for a new apartment, new rent, and also paying
for travelers and moving and finding a new job at the new
state?
It was training.
You didn't have fun?
Well, anyway, we should look for the other half of the seat.
Once it's whole again, we can see our elites.
Yeah.
All right, just move that.
Yeah, oh, I hear the lizards.
Fucking new.
I heard you guys.
That's right.
I will make sure your entire kind is distinguished.
Oh, wait, we gotta keep this.
Yeah, just move forehead.
Yeah, just abandon everything and live in a box for a while.
No problem.
It's not a war crime if, like, their kind don't have rights.
They're an invasive species.
It's like the iguana problem.
I always talk about it, but, like, apparently there's a huge
iguana problem in Florida because they're an invasive
species, and the mayor has put out, like, several
statements.
Please kill them.
It's like...
Like, we do not want them here.
They just keep coming.
Like, kill on sight.
Aguados.
Yeah, and it's been a problem for years.
They have been a huge problem in Florida.
They've been trying to kill the iguanas, but they're still
populating.
Bro, how are these fucking?
Lizard's doing so much.
All right, kill the source.
Oh, my God, it didn't kill him.
I'm actually surprised it did not kill him.
Okay, okay, buddy.
Chill.
Yeah, I don't think boars are an invasive species though.
Compared to iguanas.
Brother, I had a thought.
What if you took a stealthy approach to an expat?
Stealthy and god of what?
That's funny.
If you could call so meager a task done.
Are they?
Are Boar is actually an invasive species?
You must live with your deeds.
But do not be troubled by them, brother.
Oh?
And why not?
You are given an impossible problem.
Do not blame yourself for failing to solve it.
I'm sure the dwarves would feel differently.
This doesn't fix things.
No.
That's crazy.
But it is a start.
And a minder, brother.
That's Fatal Fine Slag we collected could be of considerable
use.
They've devastated the Midwest.
Holy shit.
They're that big of a problem?
What request do I...
Okay.
Do I have enough for more upgrades?
I should, right?
Yeah, I do.
I will grab that.
Oh, nice.
No, I don't have enough for Arteus.
Uh...
a rune on it not that I guess we're the blades oh never mind
have anything for the shield oh what the shield uh oh shit
yeah I fucking give me that shit
okay it's bad enough that hunters and helicopters are sent
to hunting oh my oh I've heard about the monkeys with herpes
yeah no there it's like we're recreating planning of the
apes But we have to start with her piece.
Thank you, the super chat bunched up.
Thank you, thank you.
I got P though real quick.
I'll be right back.
I am back.
Hello, everyone.
Let me double check.
Oh, I knew it.
Every time I mute myself, like, my go XLR.
I heard, like, apparently.
It's the biggest thing you've ever heard.
I do not know.
Also, X Factor, Meep, Aphelion, Cap, Mike, Papa, Bite.
WWE 4, Solid, Medi.
Thank you, Mr. Bridgehead.
Thank you, thank you.
Apparently, GoXLR support has finally stopped.
So if you're like, oh, what a fuck are the alternatives?
Like, so I don't know what happened, but apparently the
GoXLR no longer has, like, support anymore.
Like, they just disappeared, I guess.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
But they are no longer updating GoXLR, which is crazy
because they're, like, the streamer.
They're literally, like, the streamer mixer.
And then, like, they just abandoned it.
I don't... I honest, I don't understand.
I feel like every streamer uses GoXLR because it's so
simple.
It's, like, baby mixer.
And I like that because I'm baby.
Yeah, but then, like, yeah, they...
They literally have the...
I guess only streamers buy-in.
There's not enough streamers for the market.
The air smells a lot cleaner.
No, everyone uses GoXLR.
Because it's so easy.
It's like the easiest mixer.
Like mixing.
It's like mixing for dummies.
And that's me.
It's me.
I'm one of them.
And then like...
And they literally just...
Okay, there's...
There's Odin watching me again.
Like, I don't know, they just left.
They're like, we will no longer provide updates.
I'm like, huh?
What do you mean you're no longer providing updates?
Mir, what's the deal with Odin's ravens?
They can just transport him anywhere?
Except for the realm between realms, thankfully.
Why?
Harder to find, thanks to Dwarven Enchantments and
Iggdrasil's very own nature.
Hmm, lucky us.
We going to Dirlins?
Hope you'll be happy we fix those rakes.
Alright, here I go.
It's a hardware.
And a software.
It's both.
There's the safety office.
Well, the signer here's breaded away from that.
I'm going to grab that real quick.
But sorry, I gotta grab that loot.
I see loot and I must grab it.
Yeah, I don't know idea why they abandoned it.
making enough money I grab this I see loot and I must grab
well I make my boy grab oh did you see the whole Paramount
and Warner Brothers shit that's going on or how Pat
Paramount is like they really really want Warner Brothers
and then like Warner Brothers like like it's like he
paramounts like this the desperate boyfriend slash
girlfriend and he offered like six times they offered like
six times uh negotiations and warren brothers every time was
like no we're gonna go with netflix and they're like yeah
but like oh my god please cap it like yeah but come on baby
come on you don't you want to be with me and then the word
brothers like i i chose netflix Okay, there you go.
And like six separate times.
And now like Paramount is like being like this is illegal.
They don't know what's good for them.
They're just blinded by Netflix.
Was it eight?
Oh my god, they went up to...
like now they're like we're gonna we're like trying to
convince the board to like reject the Netflix bid being like
guys like trying to convince the board of director uh uh
yeah they're planning on suing Warren Bros too because
they're not selling to them they like they're all trying to
convince the board of directors they're like individually
being like reject the bid because you know we're so much
better just reject it reject Netflix's bid and try to
nominate like like newer people onto the board being trying
to nominate people on a board that are more like for
paramount than netflix yeah it's crazy they're so fucking
desperate we're looking for darlin you have an appointment
guys thank you for the super chat thank you thank you so i'm
gonna sue you don't sell your brand to me because you not
selling makes me very sad yeah if i can't have you no one
can.
Elect on something, pal.
Think, uh, providing a severed head around on your hip is
going to scare me into somehow approving Esther's accretion
proposal, eh?
We are looking for a prisoner of Odin's.
Yeah, they all suck, but I think Paramount sucks more than
Warner Brothers.
Friends of ours said that you could help.
Where did you get...
You chop her head off with that too, eh?
Oh.
She was my...
wife oh how dare you that's his waifu oh here that's his
wife that's his wife oh my god he's the deep get
my wife out of your mouth slap
rest of them all The ones left alive have to pay the price.
I'm afraid I can't help you with your little prisoner
situation.
But he could have answers on how to stop Odin.
And free swallowfine from the Ace here.
I'm not in the business of crushing the old father anymore.
Why is he in the business for it?
What even is this business?
He sells books?
on it.
Oh, freeing!
Wait, that's so smart.
What is it?
A fine?
He did an uprising and then the all-fotter made him a
fucking...
For fucking up my desk!
Fine.
Play it at your leisure.
Okay.
Wait, he did an uprising and then the all-fotter made him a
fucking...
Audit?
An auditor?
That's crazy.
Hey there, Joe.
What about...
Get out of my office?
Don't you understand?
You said...
No wonder everyone hates him.
Oh, uh, sure.
It gave this man a white-collar job.
The ultimate punishment bureaucracy.
Yeah.
He made him a bureaucrat.
I beg your pardon.
What a monster.
Dina, would you get a load of this?
It looks a little familiar too.
I've just got one of those faces.
Their name is Dina.
Seems to me that's the only thing you've got.
The ultimate prison of nine to five.
He gave him a nine to five job.
No!
Hey, this isn't a fine.
Not now.
There are enemies ahead.
That's unfortunate.
Alright, nice.
No, it's so true.
It's okay.
Oh, never mind.
Hello.
It's alright.
You thought I missed you?
There you go.
Bam!
Okay, where is he?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Alright, this guy.
I have to go up and kill you.
Oh, you thought hot ground makes you safe?
That's fucking right.
I am high ground Oh my god, there's so many oh Shit, I did
not realize I have so little HP now
Oh shit, whoops Fuck it.
It's fine.
I have to be angry anyway That's fine Just some extra anger
Some extra HP
All right, get over here!
Okay, nice.
Where's the last guy?
All right, it has to be the last guy, right?
Nope.
All right.
The alpha.
The alpha?
How many alphas are there?
If they're all alphas, boy, they can't all be alphas.
Then there's no alphas.
all right yeah I know I could turn it off but I just just
I've just went with it okay I had low HP anyway I think
Darlene wrote down direction the dwarf has given us a map oh
so the all fighter wouldn't know it seems to lead to a mine
beyond that mountain not everyone uses axes and arrows to
fight oh that's smart.
It's because the all-father is always watching.
So he, like, faked it.
He rage-baited.
Yeah, he tried to rage-bait me with bureaucracy, and it
almost worked.
Alright, let's see.
We got Rahad.
Where'd I go?
168.
Wait, there's something over there.
How do I get there, though?
What the fuck?
Oh, boat.
Okay, we gotta row, row, row the boat somewhere.
I go back?
Can I go back?
Oh, I can go back.
Wait, actually, no.
It should be going somewhere here, right?
There's no way I backtrack it.
Do I?
What?
Do I backtrack or is there somewhere to go here?
I feel like this is all dead ends though.
I was like, why would it take me here?
And then like, yeah, there has to be somewhere to go.
Because like, why would they fucking take me here?
And then be like, JK, you gotta go back.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
There you go.
There's a door.
No, I'm the god of boy now.
I'm a god of... I'm god of dads.
This thing looks like it can take us up the mountain.
Maybe we'll be able to see a mine up there.
Ah, nothing quite like a dwarven train ride.
He's retired.
He's a retired man!
That's the child to take care of now.
How the fuck do I get that?
Oh, I have this, like, an ability that I don't have yet.
Don't worry about that great gravestone.
Oh, does that mean I have to backtrack?
That means I'll never come back.
I'll never worry.
It's funny you think I'll come back.
A little car ride with my boy.
Choo-choo.
say it brother it was written all over his face uh well
burned i should say into his head he was driving this thing
bourbon engineering to warrant swift and enduring
retribution he is a captain of odin i and the bearer of
galahorn the true believer that one there are a few things
so dangerous in a man as lack of doubt a good soldier
follows orders
come on I can't wait to get better.
Let's look for a way to get over there.
Being sick sucks.
You know, maybe finding tears are best protection.
Seems like Odin really didn't want us to find one.
Once tears free and can be god of war again, Odin won't have
time to worry about us.
If that is his war to fight, he may have it.
Look that one bug in particular.
Look, the crow lived.
lived okay that means god wanted him to live it was god's
fate to be fair he is the god but you he is the god
activated but yes likely one belonging to barry the dwarf
builder of the great hall lure what a magic thingy oh god
not these
Fuck mother for the ass, dude.
Fuck that crow in particular.
You know what?
Fuck everything around here.
Oh, fuck.
Where is it?
Oh, it's not doable.
This one is not doable yet.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my God.
It is actually not doable.
I'm like, you fucking stupid.
Yes, it is.
And it was not doable.
He was right.
Oh, it's a crocodile.
There's a blue crocodile.
Whoa, is that a Trekkie?
What happened here?
Use caution.
I think it's dead.
Yeah?
Definitely dead.
But who killed it?
Hey, surely it died of old age, right?
Oh!
Oh, that's a bigger, bigger guy.
Oh, no.
Oh no, I should not have fucking wasted that.
Oh, did you see that?
I told you it looks so cool when I get it.
I told you.
It looks so cool if what I do eventually get it.
Okay.
Oh my god, fuck yes, I'm using the axe.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Bam!
Sick pain!
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He just keeps slapping me.
Okay.
He has the...
Fucking knew it.
That's right.
It's okay.
It just hurt the boy, not me.
I'm fine, though.
Oh, fuck.
I am no longer fine.
I am.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay.
Let me focus up.
This guy is scary.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's not fair.
I was in the middle of my attack.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm doing a worse run right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro!
Oh my god!
Okay, this is not fair.
Now it's not fair.
That's it.
There we go.
Fuck you.
Okay, there has to be like...
Okay, that's fine.
What?
That is not fine!
Okay, we might be fucked up.
Unlucky.
Where the fuck is the his?
Like, where are the his?
Yeah, this guy is strong.
The alpha.
there i see the heels because i have found the hues it's
really just there there we go
oh my god oh my god did you guys see that did you guys see
that oh my god oh fuck okay oh my god okay there we go i got
another pair
There you go.
I'm fucking grabbing this, though.
It's okay.
Oh, he missed.
Oh my god, he didn't miss that, though.
Yeah, fucking I don't!
Oh god.
There you go.
Guys, I told you.
to occupy oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa chill chill little guy
oh my god let's go third time's the chat oh wait wait quick
time event take the charges
oh shit yeah that one was tough oh yeah nice bonding time
with my boy don't you love oh hey slot the new rule okay
names of anguish oh that sounds cool yeah the first one we
found if so it was their aggression that got them both
killed okay nice so cool I told you guys it's so wouldn't
get the parries so we're i'm starting to figure out the
timing very slowly i'm figuring it out what a good
father-son bonding moment i have with my son here teach him
how to be a man that has to be what darlin was talking about
down there that is so far father what if a war with odin
isn't just tears to fight What if it's ours too?
It's not.
We're not.
We're not Norse.
We're gods.
Better gods.
We're trying to stop Ragnar.
And what if the only way to do that is war?
Let's raise.
Technically he's the only god left for his realm.
He literally killed all the gods and then be like, oh, time
to...
I guess I live in the Norse area now.
I guess I live here now.
because I killed all the gods.
What do I do?
I'm sure you lost, yeah.
Okay, I know I have to go up, but what if I go down?
I know I have to go down, but what if I go up?
Aphrodite is still alive.
What the fuck is she gonna do?
Like, there's no other...
It's just her.
Like, she can't fucking repopulate the gods.
The gods back there.
There's no other gods.
All she's gonna get is demigods.
And they're practically, they're like barely gods.
How can she repopulate if all the other gods are dead except
for Kratos?
I don't think Kratos would wanna stick his pee-pee in her.
I don't think he wants to get near crazy well yeah but he's
different now that was during his crazy psycho killing era
yeah but but he's matured now guys he's matured he's learned
I can't go there oh my thighs are just not thick enough to
jump through that fucking jump through that oh this works
though apparently oh yeah the longer jump works
oh wow okay okay
he's like no i cannot do such short jump that jump it's way
too much for my legs Oh shit.
Alright.
Oh my god, the fucking house.
Oh, I destroyed the house.
Bro, okay, did my son shot me?
Alright, there you go.
He needed pink to jump.
Fixed a broken train.
Oh, I'll fix it.
Looks like we have to get this one back on the tracks.
There you go.
I fixed it.
Just cut it off.
All better now.
Yeah.
That's how you fix it.
I'm an engineer.
Okay.
We need to go left.
Left.
That's it.
Is that left?
I meant my left.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I was like, I don't think that's
left.
We're so close.
Just a little to the left.
What?
Boy, you're making me angry, boy.
Yeah, that's it.
I was gonna say, boy, I swear to God.
You're making me angry.
It's like, there's like, the parking thing.
They're cracking.
Oh, uh, Diner.
Yeah, it's covered in algae.
I was thinking we could show it to Brock and Sindri when we
got back.
Okay, so.
We came here looking for Tyr because we don't trust Odin,
right?
If you think about it, War could...
Uh-oh.
Oh, shit.
Who is it?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Whoa, okay.
All right Don't worry.
I'm buddy mashing Get out of here My car I shoot him shoot
him don't worry shoot him A little arrow won't hurt your
papa The break stuff keep trying little brother All right,
two mothers Stop this train Oh shit, I'm buddy mashing
Chris, I'm gonna win Oh, fuck!
Oh!
Boy.
What did you do?
I think because we didn't have it.
Oh, fuck!
Oh.
That's okay.
All right.
We put him out of his misery.
That's nice.
How?
That was helpful.
I can't believe we...
Are you serious?
We...
Aw.
Nope.
All right, nice.
Oh, fuck.
Come on, bro.
Are you...
Oh, fuck.
Serious?
Oh, that's it.
That's it.
I keep thinking he's saying alpha, but it's just another...
That was crazy.
All of it.
We saved it, my little brother.
Is there anything up here?
I keep thinking he's like, alpha!
Oh.
Wait.
Hit that.
Oh.
Are you fucking serious?
He dodged?
Oh my god, he fucking just jumped over me.
There you go.
Nice.
Let's grab that.
Jesus, your enemy's everywhere.
There you go.
Oh, where?
Oh, there he is.
That's okay, my boys got it.
He has no HP.
So he can tank it as long as he can.
That's my boy.
All right, now I can loot.
Oh my god, there's so much shit.
Okay, oh, oh my god, there's this stuff here too.
Where do I go?
I'm so overwhelmed.
Oh my god, there's too many places to go.
oh my god a fucking course he was hiding down there
the loot was very oh my how did i miss boy i believe my boy
it was perfectly lined up and then he shot an arrow at him
guys it was perfectly lined up if it wasn't for my boy i
could have killed him 100 percent
I'm okay now.
What?
Oh my god, it's a stupid tiny lizard.
Oh my god, get him!
That's it.
I'm just gonna...
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, I'm so overwhelmed.
I'm like, where do I go?
I could go so many different places.
I'll go here.
So, quite the mouth you had on the train, lad.
It's just a word.
I've heard way worse from- Your word does not matter.
You lost control.
This is a PG game.
Parental guidance required.
It's not what you truly wish your last word to be.
It's shit.
It's a crisis.
Panic does nothing.
Harness it.
Let it serve you.
It's like, imagine, boy.
If your last words were shit shit shit I am disappointed
Look on the ground tracks he's mostly mine we'll need to get
past this cargo I Guess we go this way Oh Not here
How do we get past it?
Okay.
Can I freeze that water?
Freeze the water.
How do I freeze that water?
Think, Doki, think!
Can I angle this anywhere?
Maybe up top?
No.
Oh?
By the sound of it, that's not quite right.
Reuse the wooden channel?
Oh!
Okay, I didn't realize my fucking thing goes through the
wood.
Alright.
Okay, let's try this.
That's one.
There's a couple more near here.
Let's find him, yeah?
Alright.
Wait, but where do we go?
Here?
You're right, it was yellow.
It was like, Joki, the whole thing was yellow.
i was like okay you true true but it wasn't bright yellow so
can you really blame me look if it was bright yellow i would
have known that i should have frozen it
yeah read is cooperative in large scare quotes
I don't even know that those little Lord bits are important.
Like, some of them are, like, just not even Lord.
It's like the Pompeii Graffiti shit.
Wait, I'm missing one more?
I thought I'm fucking fired three.
Oh my god, this one never lit up.
Oh my god, it didn't light up because...
Alright.
okay that makes sense yeah the water put it out I was like
what did I miss count and I forgot how to count the three
like steam like valve oh yeah now I'm much HP oh that's my
boy okay I was like who the fuck was standing there creepy
ass man I might be able to get up there if you help Who?
Where is he?
Where did my boy go?
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, my God.
He literally blended in.
I actually did not see him.
He actually blended in with the fucking environment.
I lost him.
I'll head across for a better one.
Camouflage worked.
father there's a gate up here heading towards the entrance
to the mine if you can get up here i'll need your help
lifting it if oh come on you can jump that your knees aren't
that bad atreus that was close try again okay okay bro oh my
god okay i see it i see the vision
I hope you can make that jump.
Okay, okay, you grounded.
Boy, when I keep my hands on you, boy.
When I keep my hands on you, boy.
Oh, just because you have high ground, you think you can act
on tough right now?
Wet stuff to do it for you.
Ooh.
I'm gonna get my belt.
He's gonna get some ass whooping soon.
Sure hope Tears here.
Betrayus, we seek information.
I know.
Tear, tear, tear.
What happened to, you know, your dad who is also a god of
war?
So I'll tear this and tear that.
father is also the god of war as well don't know you know
this
Pompeii graffiti proof that men in all ages must ship us
thank you for the super chat lot thank you thank you i um
can't lift this alone all right let's go yes you can boy use
your legs All right, boy, you stopped fucking lifting it,
too.
I saw that, boy.
You stopped.
There's no thing here.
I'll go this way.
Looks like you found Darlene's mine entrance.
Oh, hey.
How did you get here?
Got something else?
for you.
Sindri!
What is it?
Since you're currently lacking a light source, sorry, and
have no way of seeing exactly what untold horrors lurid in
the dark, these will help.
Okay, back to your exploring now.
Oh, yeah!
Thanks, Sindri.
I got a flashlight.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Oh.
Okay.
I did not like the sound of that.
God fucking damn it, a fucking quirk.
Get over here.
I was just like, oh, just cause...
Yeah?
Oh, yeah.
You thought you were so safe.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
You're never safe.
Alright, get this guy on the fucking thing.
Don't let him have the satisfaction.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, the tiny ass salamanders too.
Oh my god, just shoot him.
Alright, they're all dead.
Alright, where do I go?
I'm truly a dad.
I'm always lost.
I'll never know where to go.
Every time I go somewhere, where I'm like, where do I go?
Where do I go?
Alright, where does this...
Where does this go?
Whoa.
You seeing this?
That huge crane's moving this way.
Okay, but what's over here?
Oh, that's the goal.
Okay, so that's the goal.
Which means there might be extra stuff here.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, the crane moved.
And why do we care about that?
Okay.
And then where is it going?
Question mark.
So why do we care that that crane moved?
What?
oh my god i'm trying to freeze this but he's just doing a
little jumpy jumps
okay the crane moved again and where is it taking it oh
where the fuck is it taking it Oh!
I understand.
Wait, but I can't even go there.
Okay, but like...
Okay, so basically what I do, I do this.
Yes, sir.
And I do that, and then it's like the slowest elevator ride
of my life.
Don't worry, I'll get there.
eventually truly is the slowest elevator
yeah we're gonna start a war you think the lads to trust him
he is eager to prove himself it clouds his judgment Truly is
a god of war.
Alright, nice.
Dead people stuff.
Nice.
Healers.
More dead people stuff.
Ripped apart by his audience.
Well, one member of his audience.
Well, Thor.
Tokyo, I've already finished and started a new game plus.
Good for you.
Yeah, but did you finish it the dokiway?
That's right.
You truly finish it.
You didn't finish it the dokiway.
I think this is it.
This is the mine.
Look out!
Oh my god.
Fucking fuck you.
Get out of here.
Well, looks like the official entrance to the mine is
blocked.
But there's gotta be another way.
You mean the way beside the entrance?
There we go.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
Oh my god, it's like swatting cockroaches.
Bro, how are these guys a threat?
Where are they all coming from?
I don't know, their homes?
They live here?
Like... Why are there so many of them?
I think I can hear the water, too.
Slow down, Atreus.
Take care.
Be ready.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
We will overwhelm you quickly.
We gotta get him.
That's right!
Boom!
I'm so angry!
My dead wife would tell me to get therapy, and now she's
dead, so I don't need therapy no more.
So that means I don't need it no more, right?
That's what it means.
I can't get therapy if that my wife just did.
That's the logic.
Bro, I swear to God.
I swear to...
Alright.
All right, here we go.
Now get rid of the kids.
Yeah, now we got rid of the children.
Yeah, we don't need orphans.
Is there anything here I missed out?
Wait, did I come from here?
Yeah, I did.
I did.
That's where I saw the trolley.
It's all right.
What?
And then let them become orphans?
They don't deserve to be in the system.
Guys.
I'm doing them a favor.
Okay, that's a shortcut then for later.
Maybe we can ride this boat thing further into the mine.
Worth a shot.
Alright, let's go to the...
Oh, no.
This...
Oh.
I do not like this...
This boat.
I know you said not to, but I can't stop thinking about
this.
We spend all of our time fighting bad stuff.
We leave them alive, they'll grow up to become Batman.
We do not know him.
We saw his shrines.
He's a leader.
He stood up to Odin when no one else would.
If he's done it before, why wouldn't he do it again?
Images from Lolland, do not tell a whole story.
To become a Robin, they need a Batman.
There's a door.
And we need to make sure that no Batman shows up.
be close oh my god there's so much here eventually i'll get
a tool to do that can't help but feel like you're angry with
me or something ever since we got to svardofarn you've been
critical of my every move if you don't think i can lead us
just say so it is not your competence that is in question
okay but what does that mean consider your intent it's
intent we
This is so much stuff.
Oh my god.
There is a lot of places to go.
This is everywhere I have to explore.
Your question from before.
about my intent i intend to help the god of war stop odin
and that means freeing him from whatever prison he's in
right now brace yourselves friends oh hey he's back and be
careful exiting that thing one foot at a time there are
loose rust nails everywhere have you sure you get all your
belongings as if i would navigate this maze of running silly
no i'm sure you'll manage that on your own i don't know the
water looks pretty clear here keyword locks yeah yeah they
might be like brain-eating amoebas in there.
Oh, my lucky knob.
Uh, ooh, it's craftable, too.
What I have equipped?
Strength?
Hmm.
I don't know.
I'm just gonna upgrade this.
Oh, I can finally upgrade my blade.
Let's go.
Oh, I'm actually a disinfectant, so these are very hygienic.
Hmm.
I'm gonna craft...
Yeah, I'm gonna craft this.
Yeah.
We'll grab that.
Oh, this is new.
Oh,
but for it?
Oh, for...
The 480?
Wait, that's good.
I'll take the 480.
Oh, wait.
I gotta grab armor upgrades.
Want something in particular?
Do I want something in particular?
No, let's just upgrade.
This...
It fits.
Yeah, I should get that.
that that might be my best piece yet today i can upgrade it
make number go up
whatever you need i'll create that's good i could yeah i'll
figure that
ah it should be good because you've got new armor doesn't
mean you should let yourself get knocked around more very
well but i have 40 defense now what's the point all right we
go this way look there's a door just across the gap here
could be right read read head i only love my mbc's detail oh
okay he read
whoops the water flows block what oh water's overflowing
where you froze that trough that's helpful okay boy I'm not
here for your smack talk right now
I'm gonna grab my belt
oh my god I see it I see it I didn't see the giant ass rock
Sounds like you four, but moving along, brother.
What next?
Yeah?
Oh!
Yeah!
That worked.
Let's get to the door.
Come on.
Alright, I'm so smart.
And I got money here, too.
I need to remember to, like, hit the barrels here for a few.
free money.
I'm learning.
See, you can teach an old YouTuber new tricks.
Well, I certainly don't think this is where Tia come is.
He's got to be here somewhere.
This mine is huge.
Treyus, what do you intend to stop Odin from doing?
You speak as if you know his plan.
I don't know his plans.
That's why we're here.
Brothers, brothers.
Odin will be desperate.
Whatever he's planning to do surely won't be to the benefit
of anyone but himself.
Yeah.
He's a very evil man.
Hey, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you can feel better soon, Doki.
I just got done with two bouts of bronchitis back to back so
I know how you feel.
You know, super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I hope it's not bronchitis.
Those are the worst.
I haven't had been getting like the crazy coughs.
Like, uh, um.
Like the ones that we're used to getting.
Like, you guys seen it.
Like, the ones that lasted, like, several months and stuff.
This doesn't feel like the bronchitis coughs, luckily.
I hope.
Because, like, when we had those coughs, it's like, it,
like, sounds worse than what I have now.
Yeah.
Hello.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just love watching you solve puzzles.
You are so... See?
See?
This dragon thinks I'm smart.
And that dragon is a representative of all of you.
Oh.
If they think I'm smart, I am smart.
What?
But if I...
Why ain't no bird?
I paid a viewer.
What are they down here?
Not to be discouraging, but it is a money not to borrow.
He paid a me.
Yeah, that is discouraging.
Yeah, that's my view bot right there.
I view bot myself to just tell me that like I'm smart.
I'm very good at puzzles.
I think that's a good use of my mind.
door up to the left behind that's maybe tier try to escape
we should look oh see guys the view was working as intended
for disclaimer reasons youtube i am not i did not pay for
any view bots disclaimer reason disclaimer for legal reasons
that was a joke youtube for legal reasons
just in case i gotta cover my tracks
silly youtube i spend my money on vbucks
why would i spend my money on that silly youtube
i got the lift to move perhaps we could ride it up to the
broken door Where's the lift?
True.
Lord Kuro says, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Give them time to learn a dumb girl is cute and you are very
cute.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, there's the lift.
Looks like we're wondering where the fuck the lift was.
We're almost there
Oh, whoops
That's it come on.
Let's take that lift up here can't be far.
How the fuck do we get there?
Boy boy, okay boy What you're missing is that I'm trying to
figure out how to get up there Oh
What?
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's stuff up here, though.
Oh, okay.
Wait, I gotta grab stuff, something over here.
We will return.
We have stuff here.
There's loot.
Oh, there's...
There's...
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Am I supposed to be here?
Wait a minute.
Ar- um.
Arnavus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, we gotta go up here first.
Where is he?
Get out of here!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god, you're fucking kids.
You're goddamn...
You're goddamn stupid children!
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god!
Okay, the kids are annoying me right now.
The kids are adoring me!
Oh my god.
Come on, it's so close to die.
Okay, there you go.
Any plans for one minute something else so when you get
there or the two year anniversary of your turn?
Of course, there's always plans.
There's always lots of plans.
plans but don't worry there's always an event for these
milestones man they give us a super chat thank you thank you
where am I oh my god like where where am I going it where
where is this place that I've like ran into oh Okay.
There is a...
But yeah, lots of fun things planned.
Always.
Alright, I'll go through this door.
I have no idea where this is gonna take me.
Oh hey, loot!
Yay!
It's not a dead end.
It's not a dead end if it's...
I don't care if you go this way.
Oh, wait, but there's stuff here.
Uh, I have to grab a tool for that.
That's silly that they think I'll backtrack.
So silly.
Let's grab this.
And now we can go back, Arteus.
Now I can go back to figuring out this puzzle.
Alright.
I shall now use my brain.
Oh my god, I can't even kill that.
There we go.
It was worth it.
I go right here.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
See?
See guys?
I used my brain.
Okay, and that should lower it.
And then that should lower it.
There we go.
Open sesame!
Yeah!
And then we grab this.
Let's think about how Tears probably feeling locked up in
this mine if I were imprisoned by Odin and finally freed
Odin would obviously be at the top of my list, but I would
just want to fight something.
Oh, there's loot on top of that Even if it was just to know
I still could
All right, there you go Secret I like how I just ignored my
son.
I was like yes, yes sir.
Yes Whatever you say, daddy's busy right now.
Yeah, loot.
Yeah.
Sure, boy.
Oh, yeah.
Should I have enough for his skills now?
I'm still level 3 locked.
Oh, I need axe upgrade.
That's why.
I definitely have...
I've not been using my blades here.
Okay.
I feel like because I'm like I feel like I'm fighting so
many I like fire enemies that I just use my axe just for
convenience God fucking damn it.
Oh my god.
I fucking hate these guys.
Oh my god I don't care if you're in danger.
You serve no purpose in society You're literally mosquitoes
I was like I don't care if if we kill off mosquitoes and it
destroys the entire ecosystems like that's the risk i'm
willing to take that's that's the risk i'm willing to take
if the entire if it destroys collapses the entire ecosystem
i'm like worth it is that a relic well that's my relic
oh Oh, shit.
L1.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck?
Nice.
I didn't even have a chance.
Okay, what is...
What did I...
Okay.
Oh, Kreeza effect grants a bonus for a short duration.
Okay, that's good.
That's actually good.
Where's the next time?
Oh, fuck!
Where was he?
Oh, my.
I got stupid.
Because you know I don't look up.
The fucker.
You're so lucky I don't look up.
Oh my god, he dodged it?
That's right.
Now you'll regret dodging it.
It's clinging to the wall.
Where?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
Come on, get over here.
How dare they exploit my weakness?
Only I can do that!
I'm literally the main character.
Alright, nice.
I feel a breeze.
A breeze.
What the fuck is my health orbs?
Yeah, I guess we go...
Oh, gotta grab this.
Grab some money, and then we go through.
Yeah, only I can bully myself.
Another empty vault.
Little brother.
Perhaps it's time we...
Don't even say it.
We're gonna find him.
Yeah, he's a believer.
He'll always believe.
Let's go.
Oh my god, every door just leads to more doors.
Please.
Boy.
boy sometimes sometimes you have to give up boy up there the
path keeps going oh please boy please is that the same more
we've seen before a father needs to know when to stop him
this mine is one enormous spiral
A good father knows when to tell his boy to give up.
He needs to stop chasing this.
But what's over here?
What happened?
Why didn't that work?
I don't fucking know.
You see a giant-ass rock?
Okay, we'll go down here first.
Just to see if we're missing anything.
This is a shortcut?
Hey, HP.
That's always good.
A statue.
Not just any statue.
That stony visage hung over the entrance to the world mill
built by Dudine the generous.
All right, let's in here.
Knock knock.
Us.
Oh no.
Oh, that's okay.
I saved it for this occasion.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
I have HP here.
Oh This is bad.
This is bad This is so bad.
I was not expecting another one Oh my god, that's a nice
dodge from my oh God, that's fine.
It's fine.
I got shields shields for days Whoa Oh shit.
Oh, that's okay.
I got shields.
Shields for days now.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
All right, there you go.
Nice.
All right, it wasn't as bad.
It's pretty easy.
Not gonna lie.
All right, that guy was easier than the last one.
Holy shit.
Bro, you got skill diffed.
That's not what I was ready for.
Another dead end.
The knob that feels cold to the top.
Rest in peace.
You said you'd follow my lead and I say we keep looking.
Watch yourself.
I will follow.
But I state what I see.
You do not agree with me.
But you will not speak to me this way.
Are we clear?
That's fucking right, boy.
Don't make me grab my belt.
How dare you speak to me like that?
Alright, let's pull this up.
Gotta tie it up the rope.
Ready when you are.
One more door.
Yeah, don't make daddy don't be angry.
Seems like we'll have to get to it first.
Oh, wait, what?
Literally that.
Come on across.
Look for another way.
I think I see a crank over here.
Crank it.
Crank it, soldier boy.
Another mental exercise.
Spends like life fighting, such as tear.
They have any desire to prove themselves.
The proof leaves a wake of destruction.
But if the wake of destruction is a bunch of bad guys, why
does that matter?
You're strong, and you did the right thing.
War does not measure the strength of a man.
I hope one day you understand.
What is it doing?
Well, that didn't quite work.
Something else we can do.
Oh, no, I'm stuck.
Oh, no.
Okay, I gotta figure out what to do back here now.
Oh, it gives me a loop-the-loop.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, it looks like this machine is dropping ore into the
water drop.
Okay.
All right, there.
Yeah, I figured it out.
I'm so smart.
Maybe there's a way to get the platform moving again.
Yay!
I'm so smart.
Look at me go.
You see the one hamster wheel rolling by.
The one hamster wheel is going over time right now.
They're out of this way.
We still have to go back and check out that last door right
yeah yeah yeah we're definitely gonna do that yeah yeah yeah
for sure we're sure son yeah run little boy run oh whoa what
telegram to be still okay that opens a shortcut I'm pretty
sure this looks familiar yeah in the spiral section of the
mine yeah we had our we have a dark soul shortcut now all
right now we go back here i'm pretty sure we're gonna have a
big ass boss fight soon
stop backseating only my dragons can backseat me because
they paid for it what did you hear that brother yeah i heard
something we're alone ears open I did hear it.
I heard someone groaning.
Yeah, he's taking my job.
He's taking my job.
There's a passage leading out.
All right, let's go.
Atreus, do my words irritate you?
It's fine.
I get it.
Bravo.
I told you, he going through puberty.
That's the worst part.
Oh.
Oh, that looked very boss fight-like.
You don't lock a door like that to secure the spare
bedclothes.
I see what we must do.
Oh, that's where a tier is.
Hmm.
I don't know.
This arena looks very boss fighty.
Atreus, your arrows.
Ready when you are.
Alright.
Three, four.
Yeah, I know.
This looks like a boss arena.
100%.
I know.
her you're oh shit those are not dwarves oh
that's not good
okay it's not a boss fight so thank god at least it's not a
boss but it's just regular people okay okay they can oh my
god He's great.
Okay, I'm sorry for calling you regular.
You're very tough, yeah, bro.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
You're very tough!
There you go.
Behind me.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice whenever I can slam dunk.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Oh, shit.
Don't be mine.
Boom.
Slashy, slashy.
That's right.
Get burned.
All right, let's.
All right.
Get the last arrow, boy.
Boop.
Oh, okay.
Oh, wait.
Open up tabs.
Oh, shit.
Isn't that God?
The Ritual God of War thing that he did.
Oh!
Alright, how big is Tyr?
Let's see.
Huh?
Oh?
Oh, he's alive!
He's looking very healthy.
What trickery is this Odin?
What game do you play?
Why didn't he just open it?
We're not with Odin.
We're the good guys.
Oh.
Oh my god.
His head is so big.
Oh.
This is the God of War.
He's just like...
He's like, see him?
Yeah.
i know you he's disappointed killer have
you come from me it's like where's your muscles bro i'm just
disappointed rather let me try bro this guy's a pussy tia
look you know me don't you you you killed meir No, no, no,
no, no.
Yeah, we brought him right back.
Yeah, stay away from me, you monsters.
What?
We freed you.
We need him.
Wait.
Holy shit, he just knocked that shit down.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God, it's cutscene.
Cutscene buff.
He seems scared.
Show him my severed head.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
No, I don't have my boy!
He was my aggro!
Oh my god.
Alright, nice.
Got him out of the way.
Alright, where's the last guy?
Alright, there we go.
Alright, nice.
Not nice though, but lost my aggro.
Uh...
I just whack it.
Oh, I just whack it.
Okay.
I don't know.
Sometimes I can't whack stuff.
I just wanted to be sure if they are the whack of both
doors.
Oh, wait, what's...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, I'm just gonna swap to the axe now.
Gotta get your ass out of here.
Give me your HP.
One ship is magic!
Atreya!
This way!
Cut him off!
Jesus!
Oh my god!
Oh, oh my god!
Oh shit!
He's WWEing me!
Jesus Christ
That's fucking that's it That's I'm angry now I'm angry
Instead of getting therapy I'm going to take my anger out on
you The healthiest way I know how
Oh my god There you go Figure it out Jesus Jesus Okay.
All right, we're fine.
That's it.
Super Ice Power!
Oh, fuck.
Never mind.
Never.
The Super Ice Power didn't work.
All right, it's fine.
Okay, Arteus does not deserve that XP, if anything.
thing like he does not deserve it boy you gotta sit down and
give me all the XP this is not EXP share right now like what
the fuck did he do okay I assume I'll come back here oh my
god he's comforting him like a fucking baby this is the god
of war I am disappointed Here, listen, I swear we're not
here to hurt you.
We're just trying to get you out.
Get away from me, please.
Take your mercy away from Odin.
Show mercy.
This is my father.
We help people.
I don't belong out here, please.
It's worse when he's angry.
Mad up!
You are the god of war!
Are you not a leader of men?
Master yourself!
Don't be a pussy!
son brought us to this place for you get it together man you
kind of role model will you be for my son you don't know me
i know what you stood for you help the giants we're
returning the favorite we we are leaving are you coming with
us jesus he's like so fucking tall oh my god
I'll take a stick.
There's a statue in the lake.
You had a spear.
I thought you needed a weapon.
Walking stick?
No.
The kind thought of it was no.
Thank you.
But...
Okay.
That's a god of war.
I, uh...
I ran because I...
don't always know what's real sounds like a bitch too
there's no shame in that brother we live five nine versus
six feet everyone hears him talk oh he's crazy crazy we want
some to yeah he's a broken man right now
i don't think he's definitely the god of pt right now.
Can you feel that?
A wind?
Blowing from over here.
Maybe there's an exit nearby.
Are there names by which I should call you?
I'm Matreus.
You already know I'm a mirror.
And that's my father, Kratos.
How does the son of a Spartan come to speak for the Yodnar?
My mother was the last giant Midgard.
Laufei?
Laufei.
I remember that name.
She tried to help people too.
He's in the light of Alpha now.
You have my sympathies.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, all I'm saying is if Gwani was here instead of this
guy, this game would be 20 hours shorter.
I think Gwani might have been fucking dead if he was in this
game.
Guys, he is.
Unless you're talking about ascended Gwani.
when he became the god of war after he died because he was
still a regular guy it was just really tall and buff let me
get that it's the least i can do god of war now here thank
you the super chat thank you thank you he only ascended to
become a god of war after his death now he'd win the human
god you can solo thor we thought you'd want to help you
freed me only to start a war I mean you are a guy of war um
so to you it's good to see you in the flesh again the mere
what's become of you I was like oh shit execrable torture at
the hands of the old father you didn't deserve such
treatment you I will say my view was a touch better than
yours we found him the top of a mountain with tree roots
wrapped all around him the only way to free him was to well
that highly pleasant for all parties involved don't worry
bemer consented to getting his head chopped off oh it's so
bright oh oh my god flashbang oh my god it's so bright
I'll kill them to track down a giant in the garden and then
he found Kratos and anyway I've promised to take these two
to the tallest peak in the realms if they'd chop off my head
and convince Freya to bring it back speak up all there I was
getting to that it wasn't all kill this kill that hey we're
back in the wetlands oh man this is just one all right here
you got this okay I've got oh Oh.
And this is your role model!
Arch!
Oh my god.
Arteus!
We almost died for this man!
That is sad.
That is truly sad.
I risked my life for a pussy.
Good kind
I don't get anything for it
Oh my god, this fucker
All right, bro, he's deep really gonna really really you're
gonna fucking uh just go over there he's gonna climb that in
front of me come we must leave before more creatures attack
you should have taken the spear defended yourself no i've
abjured you've abjured all you've become a hippie if odin
starts ragnarok oh my god we freed a hippie oh my god we
should have kept them in there how rude of yeah um boy boy
this goes against everything i do boy i ain't no getting no
hippie in the crew there it is god of running oh it's
hopeless it's hopeless this whole world is gonna die have
some damn empathy the truth god of anti-war what is it you
want for me
You speak of Ragnarok.
Oh, I got mint.
Thank you for the ring.
I had fun with dispatch.
Is that the tier you need?
I just take care of a hippie right now.
That's right.
He became god of anti-war.
Forgive me.
I am grateful for my freedom.
Oh, yeah.
Taco Tuesday.
I heard, like, you wanted to do a taco run.
yet lead you to it.
Maddie, AK, thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you.
My fight is gone.
Look, Arteus, he gave me consent to kill him.
Damage is done.
No one's killing you, brother.
Better that than to live to see bread and rock.
We do not seek war.
What?
We just want some answers.
rise thank you for the gifted ship thank you thank you it
doesn't matter the giants trust in you that's the tier we
need we need you
all I ask is for a good night's rest and maybe some food
what are we a fucking hotel now who they give the 10 gifted
ships thank you thank you bro good thank you for the gifted
ship thank you thank you thank you guys thank you for all
the memberships everyone now you'd like to finish the story
yeah now i'm like thank you for attacking us we killed them
bald who tried to kill freya i killed him but he's a
free-loader and that the giants are all gone and how they
called me loki and finding the shrines are gone when we got
to yotenheim they were all dead dead
We do not know.
I mean, not all the giants are dead.
Oh, shit.
What are those?
Reinforcements from Asgard.
The Ayn Haryar will want to investigate my disappearance
thoroughly.
Oh no.
Pah!
Are they using the sky to travel between realms?
Tricks up his sleeve, we haven't dared to consider.
They're coming down on neither Galer, too.
Will the dwarves be okay?
The time for such concerns has passed.
We must leave.
Yeah, we don't even know that we need to care about the joys
right now.
We gotta care about ourselves.
I swear to God, fight, fight.
I swear to God, oh my God, where is he running to?
Where did he run to?
Oh my God, I don't even see him.
Where did he go?
Oh my God, you little bitch.
Okay.
You little bitch.
This is our hero Get up little bro Bro tipped like a sucker
Okay Once the god of war he dedicated himself to peace All
right, wait then we don't have a god of war anymore How can
we have a god of peace if we don't have a god of war?
He's actually a hippie.
Dear, in your travels, did you ever hear the giants talk
about Loki?
I'm sorry.
That name doesn't sound familiar.
The giants are...
We're...
Very private people.
Oh, that's sad.
Perhaps after a rest.
I mean, he's also...
a giant, so you don't need to use the past tense.
You're still alive.
He just wants to chill.
Next you're gonna tell me he's vegetarian!
Alright, we got... Oh, Jesus Christ, this is a long-ass
road.
Oh my god, do we not have a fast track?
This road is so long.
A tree house.
Lord Tyr, you're really alive.
Am I?
I wonder.
Okay.
He's just tired.
I promised him some food and a room to rest in.
Ah, of course you did.
Well, let's see what we can do.
Please, come inside.
Oh, is that considered a loading screen?
Oh, that's smart.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there he is.
Oh.
That'll be fast.
It's like, oh my god, you're real.
You're actually real.
I know Jesus is fast.
I need to go grab...
Sorry, I need to go use the bathroom real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
Hello, everyone.
I am back.
John, they give a five.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
Mary, Alan, Rice, Quail, W, Nexi, Mike, Broku, Parapol,
Zechra, Taco, smug thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i always appreciate it guys thank you also to
support all right here we go yes i washed my hands i pee
really fast all my years of content creation i have trained
my bladder it's a it's a skill wait what did it bugged out
where is my son
Like...
Guys...
Oh, wait.
I'll go outside?
Okay.
Because I don't think I was supposed to be inside.
I...
Oh.
Okay.
In the morning.
Anyway, I'm back again, guys.
I'm back again.
Oh, much better.
Thank you.
I think I was supposed to be outside waiting.
I'm going to turn in.
Big day tomorrow.
So, tier.
Sounds like promises were made.
Let's see about getting us settled, shall we?
If you'll follow me.
Hey!
Come see what I got.
I think I was supposed to not go into the house when he went
inside.
I should have waited out.
Yeah.
I was like, what?
What happened?
How did I get?
here okay
he just wants a broom closet holy shit
nothing much perhaps some heart attack hard there's no way
this guy used to be the god of war there's no fucking way
the pinch of salt well I'll see what I can find there is no
way this man used to do anything war related from the
homeland i'll fix you up reform god award that's what's left
of tear huh back where i come from with satan
so have we all well ain't you philosophical that man's a
fraud they must be in the pantry kick him out
boy you could have relied on me but you Yet you picked this
man over here.
He's just a little washed.
I am very disappointed.
They're disappointed.
I want things to be the way they were.
Well, I'd like to claim a tree again.
Certain ships have sailed.
Yeah, they make anyone a god of war in these lands.
I just wish Atreus were not so.
Restless.
I care only for yourself.
I know, brother.
But holding him too tight won't keep him out of danger.
The lad can't call out this guy forever.
And I hate to say it, I think Tyr might be one of them.
I've never seen a man broken so completely.
His pain is fresh.
You expect too much.
oh pretty fair still wants to kill you that's an ally we
could use that is not an option no boy no don't go to her
that bitch oh you cannot sneak up on me like that there's
something I have to do in Midgard without me I thought we
were partners we are just wasn't sure you want to join me oh
no oh no not boy time i didn't spend anything on him not
doing that taking into account she's determined to murder
you she wouldn't really look i think it's lovely what the is
a dwarf gonna do for me i want you to continue to see the
best in people by not getting yourself murdered but we need
her what the is my germophobic dwarf gonna help
Moral support.
Hard to have fucking tear for that.
Oh, okay.
I could ruin that.
Something much less risky, but maybe could give you some
answers.
What are you talking about?
A certain old friend you haven't seen in a while.
A very giant friend.
Jormungandr?
Did you find him?
Why don't I show you?
It's just on the way to the vengeful goddess who wants you
dead.
No, she wants my dad dead.
This is different.
You know where Freya is.
No, no.
I mean, yes, but look, let's just talk to the snake first.
And then I won't take you to Freya.
How's that sound?
I mean, that sounds fine.
Maybe the big snake would help us.
Honestly, the big snake is more of a threat than the fucking
tier.
Alright, now I gotta figure out where to go.
Glad you brought your key of Igdrasil.
I seem to have dashed out without mine.
Huh.
You got sick of having house guests that fast?
What?
No.
I could just use some fresh air, is all.
Well, I hope you like it cold.
Should we swing by your cabin first?
Oh, no, we're going back.
Going back to Midguide.
Oh.
No, I meant to tell you.
Enra's dead.
Oh.
I'm very...
Sorry to hear that.
Wait, what about my two other dogs?
As wolves go, he was always very clean.
Wait, we just left our two dogs.
I just realized.
But why traumatize either of us further?
Oh, not been here.
Caught a whiff of something awful near the Helheim Tower.
Remember how to get there?
Yep, just past the oarsman.
But that's what makes you think your minganders nearby?
I know what I smelled.
Okay.
a lot's kind of happened and i need answers all right see i
don't need dad to lift this i am trying oh
see guess i am strong
i thought i was stronger
Look, we had to try it, okay?
We gotta know what that was like.
Sonic L2.
Oh, it's R2 for that.
Okay.
So, father said I cast a spell when Fenrir died.
I gotta start lifting, guys.
Accidental magic.
So I have me, like, those little teenagers with, like,
giant-ass like abs and shit i've seen those videos of like
like bodybuilding with like kids that's crazy yeah but i
lost control fray knows magic better than anyone she could
help me but not giant magic fine we'll do it your way then
sin a huge venomous snake seems much safer
like you don't grow as like as tall right if you fucking
work work out that young that's crazy i'm pretty sure that's
not healthy
there's no way that's fucking healthy
shoot the barrel it's got soundstone on it too this one oh
nice prelude it's great cindry
yeah but there's some there's like too much size.
Because, like, technically having abs is not that healthy.
Wow.
Almost like you've done this before.
Looks like there's something hidden by the horsemen.
If only I had a way to burn this.
Yes.
If only your father were here.
Oh my god.
All of these things are, like, things that only my dad can
do.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
Don't look at me.
Who knows where it's been?
Yeah, like, because, like, technically, some people who
have, like, to try to, like, show abs, They're like super-
you have to be like super dehydrated or some shit to have
abs.
It's not like super healthy in general.
What the fuck?
Must be missing something.
Oh, there it is.
So tears arm.
Your father, Othora, blood payment.
And well, he got it.
Wow, great story.
Anyway, is that...
likely to happen again sudden uncontrolled bear rampage yeah
like just show it what oh gosh guys why dude oh my god
there's a guy here we've got company got my back there yeah
that guy really wants to like shoot me you need to touch
them I like the way you think okay oh I should not use my
It's okay.
As long as I keep shooting, it'll be fine.
What is he doing?
He's just standing there!
What?
Okay.
Hey, yeah, yeah.
Can you help me?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, wow.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, actually, bro, he clearly just stood there.
You want my help or not?
All right, all right.
But if you want abs to show, you have to be, like,
dehydrated and shit.
Oh shit, bro, I'm fucking strong as hell.
Okay, this guy.
He needs to be told what to do.
He does not, he's a sheep.
He does not think for himself.
All right.
As long as they go in one by one, it should be fine for me.
yeah thank god they go in one by one thank fucking god there
you go nice thanks for sacrificing so many objects from your
bag of tricks well you clearly need help oh whatever
honestly more helpful than tier 100% he's like whoa all
right just for the sake of it what is this going over here
oh i can't pick it up i need like fire arrows i'm too young
to to carry fire to touch fire apparently oh my god i'm so
weak i'm no hp you can fix it can't you or does your brother
have all the talent after all depends is your father if I
say yes you realize you're confirming Brock has all the
talent Hawkeye from Marvel Raffles look different oh shit
what the fuck he's like Doraemon oh my god brother he's
Doraemon I just need to look out for the people I care about
it keeps bad things from happening to he has everything in
his magic pocket Norman Gander's probably not even besides
he likes me he's only eating me once I had conveniently
scrubbed that for yeah memory well yeah he has the door too
bad he's not blue that's his brother well he has everything
in the pocket told you he's gone well have you tried calling
him blowing the horns the first thing we try I'm not talking
about the horn i don't want you to see talking about just
call his name
whoa that's not weird at all oh he heard me
whoa oh yeah because he's like cold-blooded too because he's
a snake
Yeah, he speaks well.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, so he's like extra sleepy.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, there you...
There's one boy.
blooded or is it cold blooded i always get confused
because they always have to be warm to move if they're cold
they move very slow cold blooded oh yeah that i need heat
translate iron wood iron wood What is that?
What is that?
What did I even ask?
That's all you're gonna say?
It's like, goodbye now.
I must go back to sleep.
It's very cold.
Good talk.
Ironwood.
What do you think it means?
Oh, he doesn't fucking translate.
Means he should have stayed home.
Let's head back.
It's barely a translation.
All I got was ironwood.
But the door opened.
Oh, no.
Oh, we did not think this through.
Oh, I'm gonna break my fucking bow.
Would you just let me do it?
Maybe.
Okay, you do it, then.
You're so strong.
That's right.
What you gonna do?
Yeah.
Well, now that I know where she is, yeah, exactly what I'm
gonna do.
What?
Don't tell Brock I cursed.
He's unbearable when he's smart.
Wait, what the fuck?
What the...
What?
How did that work?
Baldur tried to kill her.
We had no choice.
Not sure she sees it that way.
Well, I'm not going to ask her.
The door opened.
You're absolutely right.
Which is exactly why I'm recommending you don't do this.
But I'm magic too!
Why did his magic work and mine didn't?
I'm literally magic.
Let's watch things.
Alright, that's fine.
I can bash him with my thing.
Alright, nice.
It's gonna be so fun when more enemies show up.
Because, like, two is fine.
Two is okay.
But when it starts being, like, three, I don't know.
It might start getting harder.
Oh,
wait.
Nice.
Alright, there you go.
Box to key.
Well, that's quite an excitement for one day.
Yeah!
We're so close.
Oh, dear.
What?
Why are you all deering?
What's wrong?
This is a sign.
Don't be a baby.
It's snow.
Not to drop you this time.
Yeah.
Yay.
Just step between the realms then.
You know it doesn't work that way.
Though sweet vessel, I wish it did.
I jump into my arms.
Ah!
Been so scary!
I sincerely hope I never have to do it again.
Look at that!
That easy.
Well, if I can't stop you, then this is as far as I go.
What?
I'm gonna stay and fix this.
Suit yourself.
Wait, what do you mean?
Who's gonna be my throwy man?
Oh my god, I got new skills.
Okay, we gotta upgrade this shit.
Okay, wait.
Yeah, we need... Oh my god, that's the only thing I can
upgrade.
Great, okay.
Oh, I can upgrade more.
That's good.
Sonic Arrows.
Okay, yeah, we'll do that.
Oh, my God.
Now it's just me.
Okay, this is not good.
I don't think I can break this.
I need to find another way around.
This is not good.
I didn't think it was a one-man mission.
I lied it under my shirt.
And besides, it's a reminder to be better.
You need a murder weapon to be a better person.
It makes me feel brave, okay?
Is that such a bad thing?
When it leads you to believe you can convince Freya of
anything, yes, it is.
I mean, a murder weapon.
It's good for...
I mean, it makes me feel like I'm invincible.
Oh my god, who the fuck threw that?
Oh my god.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh, it's fine.
Now it's fine.
Yeah, it's good for myself.
I see.
Rock says some people run better on chaos.
I think he's right.
What makes you think that a player here?
Ooh, use his brother against him.
We can't just do nothing and we're out of options.
Living is an option.
Yeah, but that's not...
But don't you like the risk?
Potential of maybe dying.
As long as I go up and forward.
We're doing what we love.
Yeah, that's why we have extreme sports Yeah, with the fuck
it, we ball
Fucking you, I knew you weren't real I knew you weren't real
That's right, what you're gonna do now Oh, he doesn't know
what Oh, shit, oh shit, what the fuck How did you get here?
I was like, how was you good?
way to get up here?
Okay, I did not know there was a way to get up here, guys.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
See, look at that.
We're all chilling right now.
they can't even reach me.
And this guy's stuck.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
He's still alive?
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, just to be sure.
Okay, just leave no survivors, you know?
Alright.
More soundstone.
There has to be a...
Oh.
I guess there isn't.
I was like, there has to be something for me to shoot at.
It's blocked.
Needed to destroy the Sonic piece first.
Okay All right, I just need to get a different angle on the
soundstone Easy oh shit Get out of here.
That's fucking right.
Oh, okay.
That was sick That was actually sick
That's called strategy
Played a lot and live the king Okay, nice.
More crafting materials.
Or that is just bonus.
And what the fuck do I go?
That's just loot.
What?
Really, all that got was loot?
Man.
My father could see me now.
Oh, here.
It's the whole...
I wouldn't have to hide things if he just trust me.
How can I trust you?
you are yeah that's a good point oh no oh no i started lying
no could i not say the same no oh no guys this is bad
What?
What the fuck did I do?
What is that?
Oh, okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, is that a shield?
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that was a lot stronger.
All right, let's just slowly kill these guys.
There you go.
Oh!
That's sick.
I parried it.
Yeah.
Yeah, but then there was like the R1 and the M2.
The L1 are one shit.
And I was like, what?
Oh, he fell down.
Oh my god, I couldn't just done that.
Yeah, but like, how come... What was the... Oh, this.
I don't choose Truster.
I want you to... Oh, the cooldown.
I just saw the cooldown.
I noticed it.
It was because I didn't... I didn't realize there was a
cooldown for that.
I was like, what the fuck is the move?
I did it, but then it didn't show up again.
Which because you didn't have the...
Oh.
Arteus, why did you never do the shielding thing when you
fight with your dad?
Arteus.
Oh, oh dear!
Oh.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, where the fuck did the...
Where the fuck did the deer come from?
from wait a minute how did a deer get up here did it climb
up here there's no way i didn't oh shit oh i'm saying i
don't know how the the deer got here
oh what the wait the deer's dead now i just saw the deer
I literally just saw him.
Alright.
It was a deer.
Yeah, I was like, bro, what happened to him?
Guess I'm going the right way.
Oh my god, it's all the way down there.
Get out of here.
I feel like my melee attacks are stronger than my goddamn
bowie.
arrow which does not make sense to me I should have enough
right to upgrade my stuff no all I've been doing is shooting
okay which one is not real or which one is real oh I don't
trust you guys might come back alive Oh, it's you.
I fucking knew it.
I can tell.
Oh, my God.
That's fucking rent.
Are you fucking...
Okay, it's fine.
There you go.
I'm just gonna maintain it.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
Okay, the aim assist actually fucked me over there.
I don't know if you saw that, but my aim assist kept
dragging up.
It was dragging me up to, like, him instead of the...
Instead of the actual target.
There you go.
Okay, that was sick, though, Arteus.
Oh, I could charge up this?
wait what I didn't know I could charge up this fuck this I'm
putting shooting this guy I can go up to him get over here
get over here nice oh you're still alive he was still alive
oh there has to be a jar here
Oh, there it is.
Fire jar.
I will say Arteus is more fun to play because it's like
shooting a gun.
I enjoy his mechanic more because it feels like I'm just
playing an FPS game.
Oh, what?
I got this, right?
Yeah, I do.
I got this.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, I shoot your feet.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit!
That's right.
Got your foots.
Got your featsies.
Got blocked forever.
Freya shouldn't be much farther now.
Just need to look out for that big door.
Alright, I'll grab this too.
Dirty Hanzo player.
I'm not even using mouse and keyboard, too, guys.
Look at that.
Character development.
I'm getting better at controller now.
That's real character development.
Oh, hey.
Yeah?
Yep.
That's the door.
Hello, down there.
Hey.
Come to your senses yet?
Yes.
I mean, I'm not changing my mind.
Oh, shit.
You do have doubts.
That's right.
You never do.
Better than having regrets.
I'm not sure I agree with that.
But by all means, keep going and you might find those too.
Just like you little shit.
I'm sure that fucking came over here.
I was just like, boys will be boys.
I'm going through puberty.
Hey, Freya.
What?
Can't I pay an old friend a visit?
Nothing wrong with that, right?
I mean, just because I'm responsible for the death of your
son doesn't mean...
I can meet your new son.
Okay, yeah.
You can restart with me.
Is that for you?
Am I wearing this around my neck?
The arrow tip that killed your son.
Jesus.
That's a great question.
I'm so dead.
I'll be like, for you, don't you have...
You want a new son, right?
We can restart.
You and I.
Here goes nothing.
It's not weird.
And I know magic.
And I can feel pain.
It's the best of both worlds.
And I'm not completely insane.
You should have stayed with Sindri.
What?
Isn't that what Boulder is?
Like she gave him?
Um.
He made it so that he could never suffer pain.
Feel pain.
You sent you?
No!
He doesn't know.
And I'm not evil.
You shouldn't have come.
He took my son.
What makes you think I won't do the same?
You're better than this.
Oh.
Oh, she's been crying.
look I brought you the arrow that killed your son out of
goodwill would stake your life on it what do you know of me
I know you haven't killed me yet so while you're thinking it
over why don't you let me go and I could tell you why it
came if you mean to plead for your father save your breath
his fate is sealed but you know get to Odin nor do I need to
he's like I can't kill Odin so I'll kill the second best
thing that's crazy that he came to Midgard he came to us
offered peace if we don't move against him claims Ragnarok's
already been averted he lies maybe but if you know girl's
prophecies you know it depends on an army of giants but
there's no giant giants wait for war in Jotunheim they're
all dead I've been there there is no giant army there are no
giants at all just me huh you in
Jotunheim you learn the truth my mother was the last
guardian of our people in Midgard and and that's not all the
Giants have prophecies about me they know me as pro those
are crazy eyes okay never fuck crazy bro holy shit I think
maybe stare of a thousand miles help stop Odin somehow but
since all the Giants are dead and you won't fight Odin and
he's already won why are we working together now that you
can fight again I am far from whole okay okay but we found
here maybe if you spoke to him here is alive yeah yeah we we
broke him out a little bitch but yeah impossible the nine
realms are closed to all no we opened up the way we just
don't know where to go next but if we all band together
enough enough oh leave
this place go and do not return what go before I change my
mind I'm like so high do not expect the same mercy for your
But what the fuck?
I'm trying to put a team.
The Norse Avengers.
I mean the Avengers practically like, I mean Thor was
already in it so.
What if we made the Avengers but they're all just Norse
gods?
I know she's so Sundae.
Like, she didn't kill us, so that's progress, honestly.
You're right.
Like, she didn't kill us, so, like, we can get in.
She just needs a bit of time to think over it, you know?
She needs some time, guys.
I think we're in.
I think she wants to join my team.
Yeah, baby steps, guys.
Baby steps.
So I'm not dead.
But I didn't get any answers.
So this all might have just been the guardian of it.
injuries.
All right, up we go.
Down we go.
It's a good thing I like climbing.
Okay.
All right, we go this way.
Oh nice, look.
Oh, hey.
I made it.
What?
I talked to her on, um, yeah, bad news about that.
Uh, where's your necklace?
Huh?
Oh, I was thinking and I, uh, got rid of it.
She took it, didn't she?
Uh, today was your lucky day.
So tell me, how did it feel to run on cash?
chaos.
I...
Oh!
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, she'll come to fix...
Oh, she did.
She did.
I was gonna say...
I'll be like, Freya's just gonna show up right here, right?
She did not show up, guys.
Oh.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, fuck it.
Just slam dunk it.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
That's easy.
And that guy wasn't even that high.
Oh my god, there's more.
There was more people.
I was like, look at that.
That's pretty easy.
The other way, I know there was more of them.
There you go.
Nice.
I'll repair it later.
Let's get out of here before something else tries to kill
us.
Yeah, good idea.
I hate to bring it up, but are we telling your dad about
this?
clean and all no way he'd kill you right yeah speaking of
coming clean i need your opinion on something what is it
something i've kept from my brother for a long time do they
ever quit wait wait what what is he gonna say wait what what
what was the opinion no oh
my god I'm so... I guess we'll never know now.
We'll never know.
He will never know.
What was the lore?
You were saying?
Long before you were born.
There was an accident at the forge.
Oh, thank God.
What?
Is that why he's blue?
I couldn't accept it.
That's why he's blue!
I went to the Lady of Souls and Alpine to steal him back.
legions of souls tried to stop me i can still feel them
crawling all over my skin thing is i could only get three of
his more soul parts back cindry brock just thought he got
knocked out i've been lying to him ever since it's been
eating at me lately wait but what's the what happened with
the fourth soul right to know that's why he's just murdered
as should you with your father that's not the same thing How
is he not normal, though?
He seems pretty normal to me.
What makes him not normal?
He's only three, four, or something.
I mean, he was already a dwarf, so, like, is there really a
difference?
But what makes him not normal?
He seemed pretty normal.
He's blue.
Doki.
Okay.
But other than being blue, though, Other than being blue,
what else is wrong with him?
I don't understand.
Like, yeah, yeah, he's blue, but that's it.
It doesn't seem too bad.
He's an angry smoothing.
All I'm saying, it doesn't seem that bad if he's just blue.
You did a good thing.
You saved Brock's life.
I made a choice.
Oh, Warren.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's an angry smith.
What do you mean?
A choice.
I...
I couldn't be alone.
Oh.
The other dwarves when they saw...
What's wrong with him besides being...
Popplot.
Thank you.
Oh, they got shot at them because he's blue.
Let's go home before Father wakes up.
That might be the best idea you've had all night.
Trey.
Trey?
It's a...
What's a nickname?
Oh, my God.
The other dwarves kicked him out because he's blue.
That's so fucked up.
That's crazy.
So I'm not allowed to give you a nickname?
what that was whatever loke look that was worse well then i
heard it when i said it all right shall we dwarf racism
yeah what do you think it's weird that is blue did his
brother not fucking look in the mirror and be like why the
am i blue like especially the other drawers fucking What's
like being racist towards him.
Tear may not be everything you expected, but a failure.
You saved him from a terrible fate.
That's not nothing.
And hey, maybe he'll be some help with us yet.
Maybe.
I guess I'm blue now.
Maybe he's just colorblind.
He's probably already got our next hiding place all picked
out.
Well, let's not make it worse.
He can look into a pool of water and be like, why am I blue?
He'd be like, oh, water is blue.
blue natural but quickly
are we going oh wait where did he go okay that's like where
are you going oh he's gone that is not the risk that
concerns me do we trust the path they would put us on i
trust their wisdom and this is the closest thing to hearing
directly from them you are certain the giants would not come
to war i said that they were wise in my experience that goes
with being peaceful.
Oh, little brother.
Told you we didn't worry.
Atreus, where have you been?
Pee?
You're all hungry!
It was a very long pee.
Is everyone as well rested as I am?
Be right down.
Mm-hmm.
this sausage uh sure why not wait what what else would it be
is that why he uses his hands to eat i suppose you'd like to
try cooking for this law oh when you have three out of four
souls you don't know how to use utensils and also doesn't
know how to cook Don't you look a little blue?
Alphan.
You hate Alphan.
Why would we move there?
Wait, is that where all the elves live?
Seeking information.
The shrine of Groa, young one.
Your father tells me you found it there.
Groa?
The knowledge keeper?
Oh, maybe there's a secret there I can unlock.
I?
You better than the seer who saw everything.
Hmm.
you um never mind that's great i'll find hey don't go
forgetting this what'll get you there oh oh it's the the egg
thing you know what i'm gonna build a bigger table what
so in my soul as if i eat rice with my hands apparently i
mean that's what he said he's He has three out of four
souls.
Like, try to figure out what makes him not normal.
Like, other than being blue.
You're really up for coming with us?
I am.
Whenever you're ready.
Well, whenever your father's ready, I should say.
If my counsel might help you towards the answers you seek,
it's the least I can do to repay you.
Plus, I think it will do me well to see the light of Elfheim
again.
Hmm.
That Elf light is some good shit.
and also bud he used to have hair when he had four souls
all right now i'm dad again so where did this plan come from
oh from amir of course i was merely asking how you found me
and he explained the secret prophecies inside the yodnar
shrines fascinating from there we set to taking stock of
which shrines we'd seen at which point your father recalled
finding growth we not have forks i just feel actually go to
alpine the prudent course of action became so an area lost
step for the world's smartest man even without feet if
you'll forgive the levity i was always fond of her talks you
know right and it's good to see yeah 25 had the hair why is
he building a table
All right, my companion slot is empty.
Oh yeah, he has an accessory now.
Now he has bling.
All right, I don't think I have anything to upgrade, really.
Oh wait, uh, yeah.
Now everything is fine.
I mean, armor-wise, maybe?
I feel like, nah.
I think my current armor is the best so far.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
It's perfect.
Once... What do you mean?
I guess for...
Oh, I guess for Sig...
I mean, he doesn't really have a place to go.
I forgot about it.
I was like, what do you mean?
It's perfect for all four of us.
Right behind you.
I'll meet you at the gateway presently, friends.
Alright.
Where are we going now?
Okay, I'll film.
area right excuse me sir the squirrel oh it's fraudsy i
promise i'll be brief i assume my goodness what a strapping
physique capable of an astounding variety of acts of
violence i imagine what is happening this must be the
squirrel that chains the world tree that delectable aroma
It's me!
Let's go.
Ah, yes.
Amber resin.
Delightfully nutty with a hint of squidding.
Not one for gastronomic exploration, I see.
Wait.
What?
If you're Radatosker, why are you so different when we
summon you for help?
It's a long story.
What did he look like before?
I forgot.
But you are correct.
I am indeed Radatosker.
The one you know as Ratatascar is merely one of my spectral
aspects.
And the particularly nasty one at that.
I consider him so far removed from my self.
It's when he used to summon shit.
Speaking of.
Yeah.
When Arteus used to summon stuff.
Oh.
I suppose that was to be expected.
Anyway.
Now that I've polished off all this resin for you.
Would you like the seed back?
it is the seed indeed a seed of igdrasil to be precise since
my dwarven tenants performed their little reconfiguration
you'll need seeds like these to open up new destinations on
my tree your tree yeah it's like this is the world tree
nobody owns it squirrel just because you got here first
doesn't mean it's yours it's the world
Oh.
So that's why good master Brock needed an alfheim seed.
Clearly you have important matters afoot.
That seed you found unlocks Nifleheim of all places.
A realm as ancient as it is vaguely sticky.
Swortleheim remains an alfheim.
We'll do enough of them later.
Okay.
you can tell me the tale of your prior visit to the land of
the elves sure i can we killed them the end that's the story
he's like i don't i don't know we fucking we could pick up
some elves and then kill them the end she can't leave
midgard that's terrible so then we fought our way through an
army of dark elves to get to the light you interfered in the
elf war not by choice and they attacked us.
The dark elves were covering it with their eyes.
When we freed it, light elves came back.
He seemed better in Alphine.
Huh.
Did they now?
Alright.
Let's go to Alphine.
Alphine.
Because we're trying to reignite his passion for war.
If we keep beating up people, he'll start loving war again.
that's the strat broken history ah not exactly an easy fix
for that i'm gonna call it here guys i think this is a good
stopping point a new world i know we literally completed the
dwarf world so like i think this is a good stopping point oh
my god already fucking already played there's no way okay oh
okay it's i played six seven hours of this okay i was gonna
stay 21 hours but i realized the time all right oh yeah i
made some really good progress uh but yeah for those who
don't know tomorrow the special sponsored stream is uh the
early access preview of deadpool for season six so uh i will
be streaming that on twitch uh so please follow me on twitch
for don't it's at dokeybird it's literally the same thing um
and uh i think it's like 2 p.m psc and it'll be drops we're
gonna get to see all the cool things that Deadpool's gonna
bring for those who don't know Deadpool has three roles it's
tank support and dps and it's fucking crazy I was so
overwhelmed looking through like when I was like doing like
a quick look through of Deadpool I was so fucking
overwhelmed so like he is a lot he is a lot it's not like um
but it's like each role so it's literally three new
characters it's not one new character it's three new
characters and they're all Deadpool support Deadpool and
Tentik Deadpool have their own abilities and util
specifically for like that role so it is the crazy part is
that he was categorized as zero stars I was like how the
fuck is this man zero stars um yeah yeah you're not making
it you'll find out tomorrow so I will be doing early access
tomorrow at 2 p.m pst I might start to stream a little
earlier I might warning for everyone so i might tweet that
i'll be like oh starting to stream at 150.
uh but anyway guys i'm gonna rest my voice now i am tap my
voice is tired um and it needs a lot of rest uh because i
feel like my recovery for the last couple of days has slowed
down um because my throat it's just my throat honestly like
everything else is almost gone it's just my throat but as
always everybody thank you all for coming to stream thank
you for uh subscribing thank you for the um for memberships
Thank you for the super chats.
And as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture, check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Okay, I'll take you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Loki.
Thank you, to you guys, Dragos, too.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, bye, my merch.